the
hearing will come to order
today the senate is holding its first
oversight hearing of the federal bureau
of investigation
the first since july of 2019. this is
also fbi director ray's first appearance
on capitol hill since the january 6th
insurrection
director ray welcome back at the outset
i want to extend my condolences
for the loss of fbi special agents
daniel alfin
and lauren schwarzenberger who were
killed last month in the line of duty in
south florida
tomorrow mark marks the eight weeks that
have passed
since an armed mob stormed the u.s
capitol
inside it i'm sorry to say by the
president trump
administration and determined to subvert
our democracy
by disrupting the electoral college
count
as senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell said quote there is no
question
none that president trump is practically
and morally responsible for provoking
the event of that day
while this these efforts to overturn a
free and fair election were ultimately
unsuccessful
the trauma of that tragic harrowing day
lingers on
this timeless symbol of our democracy
still bears the scars of that attack
the attack caused the senseless deaths
of capital police officers brian siknik
and howard lee mcgood
and d.c police officer jeffrey smith
countless police officers staff
journalists
and members of congress remain haunted
by the sights and sounds of that day
the neo-nazi symbols and confederate
flags paraded through the hollowed halls
of the united states capital
a noose and gallows constructed on the
grounds outside the capitol
the sinister shouts of hang mike pence
and where's nancy
the extremists carrying zip ties and
clad and tactical gear
worst of all the violent assaults on the
u.s capitol police and d.c metropolitan
police department officers who bravely
sought to protect us from the siege
and the fd fbi has warned us that the
insurrection could be a quote
significant driver of violence in quote
in the future along with quote
the shared false narrative of a stolen
election close quote
so we must not forget the horrors of
january 6 or allow revisionists to
rewrite what happened that day
i'd like to turn to a video to
demonstrate the scale of violence and
the hate that we witnessed
it's this cloud of smoke broken flag
poles
everything in the rotunda just laying
there on the floor
we're told to uh get helmets
riot helmets you just see a sea
of people and then you look down and you
see officers fighting
with these people pepper spray smoke
grenades gas grenades
i see speaker pelosi being evacuated and
i hear them tell her you know the
capital has been breached the staff
went under the table barricaded the door
turned out the light
and were silent in the dark for two and
a half hours
not knowing how long you were gonna have
to be there not knowing when you could
come out not knowing
if you were going to come out fought
with these people who were prepared
for a fight they had on gas masks
they had on body armor they had on
tactical gear
bulletproof vests they were ready to go
there were so many calls on the radio
priority help help somebody's trapped
we need help shots fired this is when
officer dunn encountered a couple in the
crowd
who began hurling the most vile of
racial slurs at him
a black officer he was called the n-word
more than a dozen times
you say hey just voted for joe biden
guys
hey everybody just voted for joe biden
they said
you i was scared i was absolutely scared
one point i said
how was this going to end it was just a
double door
with glass panes that was pushed out
just but i ended up getting pinned there
by the crowd there's a guy ripping my
mask off and he uh
he was able to rip away my baton and
beat me with it and uh
you know he was practically filming at
the mouth we got dozens of officers down
and you got the nerd to be holding the
blue lives matter flag cause one of the
guys kept walking by
the other one pulled out his badge and
said
trust me i understand we're doing this
for you buddy and he's got a badge
he shows me his badge five people lost
their lives that day including capitol
police officer brian sicknick
they beat police officers
they fought us they had confederate
flags
in the u.s capitol i got called and
a couple dozen times today it wasn't
just a
mob or a bunch of thugs you know they
were terrorists
they tried to disrupt this country's
democracy
that was their goal is this america
is this america what the hell just
happened
the hate on display that terrible day is
not a new phenomenon in our country
america's first domestic terror
organization the ku klux klan
was born in the aftermath of the civil
war to terrorize formerly enslaved
african americans
as judge merrick garland noted at his
nomination hearing the department of
justice
was founded during reconstruction to
quote secure the civil rights promised
by the 13th 14th and 15th amendments
he went on to note that the first
attorney general opponent appointed by
president grant
led quote a concerted battle to protect
black voting rights
from the violence of white supremacists
successfully prosecuting hundreds of
cases against members of the ku klux
klan
the insurrectionist who stormed the
capitol on january 6 did not wear white
robes and hoods
they might as well have they are the
latest incarnation
of violent white supremacist movements
that has terrorized fellow americans on
the basis of their race
religion and national origin for more
than 150 years
let me be clear at the outset i've said
this on many occasions and it bears
repeating
i condemn all violence regardless of
ideology
i hope my republican colleagues will
join me today in acknowledging as the
department of homeland security found
last october
that violent white supremacy is quote
the most persistent
and lethal threat in the homeland i hope
they'll also join me in unequivocally
unequivocally condemning the big lie
that the november 3rd election was
stolen
a falsehood which the former president
continues to spread
which helped provoke the january 6
insurrection
and threatens to incite future attacks
as the january 6 attack on the capitol
demonstrated for too long our federal
government
has failed to address the growing
terrorist menace in our own backyard
i have been sounding this alarm for some
time in 2012 i held a hearing in this
committee
on hate crimes and domestic extremism
following the horrific massacre of six
worshipers
at a sikh gurdwara in oak creek
wisconsin
perpetrated by a white supremacist in
early 2017 i introduced the domestic
terrorism prevention act with
congressman brad schneider
a bill that would enhance the federal
government's efforts to prevent domestic
terrorism
during the trump administration i led
multiple letters to
attorney general barr and to you asking
the steps that were taken by the
department of justice and the fbi to
combat the growing threat of white
supremacist violence
i asked why the bureau made the
inexplicable decision
to stop tracking white supremacist
incidents as a separate category
of domestic terrorism and still awaiting
the response
meanwhile the threat posed by domestic
terrorists and in particular white
supremacists and other far-right
extremists
has only continued to grow the 2015 mass
shooting at mother emanuel ame church in
charleston south carolina
where a white supremacist killed nine
members of the church
the 2018 mass shooting at the tree of
life synagogue in pittsburgh
pennsylvania
where white supremacists killed 11
members of that jewish congregation
the 2019 mass shooting at the walmart in
el paso texas
where a white supremacist targeted
latinos killing 23 people
and many many more far too many
americans particularly people of color
and religious minorities
worry whether their community will be
next to be devastated by tragedy
despite the scope of the violent white
supremacist threat
former president trump and his
administration unfortunately downplayed
the threat posed by white supremacists
the trump administration never set up a
task force to combat
the numerous incidents of deadly
terrorist violence by white supremacists
and other extremists it was only after
the black lives matter activists
protested last summer
against police misconduct that the
administration found the need to
establish a task force to address
and i quote anti-government extremists
and a recent report in the new york
times details how the trump
administration's baseless efforts
to paint the far left as the real
domestic terrorism threat quote
diverted key portions of the federal law
enforcement
and domestic security agencies at a time
when the threat
from the far right was building
ominously
to put this challenge in context even
conservative writers
believe we are now facing a
constitutional crisis
for the first time ever we have failed
to have
a peaceful transfer of power and many
are questioning
the legitimacy of the current
administration the fact that this
divisive political force is hateful and
violent
challenges all of us to redouble our
efforts
i join my republican colleagues
unequivocally in condemning left-wing
violence
but let's stop pretending that the
threat of antifa
is equivalent to the white supremacist
threat
vandalizing a federal courthouse in
portland is a crime
it should be prosecuted to the full
extent of the law but it is not
equivalent
to a violent attempt to overturn the
results of elections
nor is it equivalent to mass shootings
targeting minority communities
this false equivalency is an insult to
the brave police officers
who were injured or lost their lives on
january 6
as well as dozens of others who've been
murdered in white supremacist attacks
we need to be abundantly clear clear
that the white supremacists and other
extremists are the most significant
domestic terrorism threat facing the
united states today
i hope everyone in this room can look at
the facts and acknowledge this
and we can come together on a bipartisan
basis to defeat this threat
now i'd like to turn to ranking member
grassley thank you mr chairman
and thank you director ray for being
here
as opposed to being virtual like we have
some
people testifying
we all agree that what happened at the
capitol january 6th
was a desecration of our shared values
it was an attack on the seat of
democracy
those who engaged in in violence
disgraced our country
and we know the statistics at least
seven people
including one u.s capitol police officer
died as a result of that day
also know that two officers committed
suicide
and we know that hundreds were
injured and of course
we expect that god watches over them and
their families
those who broke the law must be
prosecuted
and congress needs answers especially
about one officer brian sicknick what
happened to him
in pursuit of the facts related to
january 6th
senator durbin and i have sent oversight
letters to the fbi
and other agencies to date
we haven't received any productions
it's difficult to hold a hearing today
without
records so the fbi must fully respond to
congress
however i'm pleased to see that many
investigative cases are
progressing around the country
as i've noted before the ultimate
responsibility for this attack rests on
the shoulders of those who
unlawfully entered the capital i've also
made
very clear that everyone involved must
take responsibility
for their actions that day including our
former
president now in the wake of
january 6th we must seriously examine
the threats of domestic extremism
but unfortunately this threat isn't
limited
to the events of that terrible day to
fully address
it we must examine the forms of domestic
extremism
that span the ideological spectrum
and i hope this doesn't put me opposite
senator durbin on this
issue because i just heard him and i
don't think
i disagree with anything that he has
said
but a narrow view of these matters
would be intellectually dishonest
we're not serious about attacking
tackling
domestic extremism if we tolerate
mobs that attack some police officers
but not all police officers
we're not serious about tackling
democrat domestic extremism
if we care about some government
buildings being attacked
but not others we're not serious about
tackling domestic extremism
if we only focus on white supremacy
movements
which isn't the uh the only ideology
ideology that's responsible for murders
and violence yes white supremacy
movements
may be considered the most dangerous at
a given time
but somehow it wasn't last summer or
won't be when the next foreign attack
is attempted we must call
extremism wherever it happens
across the board left to right every
time
we must focus our resources to try to
see as much of it
coming as we possibly can wherever it
comes from
it hardly registered in the media when
marshals
and secret service officers defended
courthouses
in the white house that's not senator
durbin's fault that's the media's fault
they were called stormtroopers by the
speaker of the house
like they aren't even human beings vice
president harris
when she was a senator supported the
minnesota freedom fund
an organization that helped bail out
violent rioters in minnesota
13 staffers of a candidate for president
at that time boasted on twitter
that they donated to the group according
to one
news report the group paid 75
000 to get one man out of jail
when he was charged with attempted
murder for allegedly shooting at a
police officer
during the may protests one of the most
upsetting aspects of
violence this summer has been the
targeting of
innocent law enforcement officers just
like
innocent law enforcement officers were
targeted
during january 6. we had more than
700 officers being injured between may
27th
last year and june 8 last year
officers have been assaulted slashed
struck with hammers
baseball bats and blinded by lasers
67 secret service officers
were injured during a three-day siege on
the white house
which caused then president trump
to be brought into a secure
bunker we also remember on television
seeing
our colleague from
kentucky having a hard time getting
to the white house when he wanted to go
there sometime
last summer we also had the church
across the street was
lit on fire across the street from the
white house
as part of that continued left-wing
assault
more than 300 people were charged
federally for their roles
in those months of violence 80 of those
charged related to the use of arson and
explosives at least 14 000 people were
arrested in 49
cities at least 25 people died in
violence
related to the riots there has been 280
arrests
as a result of the january 6 attack
compared to more than 1
000 arrests as a result of riots
just in portland last year it's been
estimated that
insurance losses of summer's civil
unrest
possibly exceeded two billion dollars
it's been a relatively frequent site
at summers violence events to see
individuals acting in coordination
holding the a symbol for antifa
and as i said before i don't disagree
with anything i heard senator durbin say
this morning
but we did have an admitted atifah
adherent in portland murder a
conservative protester
supporters of that group have been
charged federally for violent
promoting riots and using molotov
cocktails even after president biden's
electoral victory
can you believe this antifa rioters
attacked the
oregon democratic party headquarters
and they did that on inauguration day
you'd think the results of the election
ought to satisfy
if that's what they wanted to accomplish
in an anti-trump
manner of getting rid of the president
is trump
or trump as president let's not forget
about left-wing activists who opened
fire
on 24 republican congressmen and hit a
capital police officer
a congressional aide a lobbyist and
representative steve
scalise at a baseball field in
alexandria virginia
and of course our colleague on the other
side of the aisle had left
life-threatening injury at that time
in light of these ever-present left-wing
threats
i'm concerned about resource shifting
talk among our colleagues across the
aisle
let me say this clearly we aren't going
to defund
the anarchist extremism program or
any other domestic terrorism program
it can't be that the fbi needs a fully
funded art theft
program but can't afford to fight both
right-wing
and left-wing extremism we must examine
the issue of domestic
terrorism broadly very broadly
to include all forms of
political extremism domestic
terrorism whether it's wherever it falls
on the political spectrum
no serious oversight activity and no
other policy decisions can be made
without doing both
as we move forward i encourage
both houses of congress to re
review not just the events of january 6
but also domestic violent extremism
across the board and the threat it
brings
to our families and communities and let
me emphasize
three times now nothing i heard with
senator
durbin say do i disagree with
but we need real answers on extreme
involvement on pre-planning
and coordination and we also need to
know what happened to officer
sicknick in closing i want to express my
sincere thanks
and appreciation for law enforcement and
in part
particular the capitol police for their
efforts
on the job and during the terrible
events of january 6.
they're they're truly heroes
a yield thank you senator grassley
directorate would you please stand to be
sworn
do you affirm the testimony you're about
to give will be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you god
thank you let the record reflect that
the director answered in the affirmative
and now director you may proceed with
your testimony
trying to go there we go so good morning
chairman durman ranking member grassley
members of the committee i appreciate
the opportunity
to be here today to talk about the great
work of the men and women of the fbi
let me start with a quick update on the
investigation
into the january sixth attack here at
the capitol
i was appalled like you at the violence
and destruction
that we saw that day i was appalled that
you our country's elected leaders were
victimized right here
in these very halls that attack
that siege was criminal behavior plain
and simple and its behavior that we
the fbi view as domestic terrorism it's
got no place
in our democracy and tolerating it would
make a mockery
of our nation's rule of law the rule of
law of course
is our country's bedrock and it's our
guiding principle at the fbi
that's why the fbi has been working day
and night across the country
to track down those responsible for the
events of january 6th
and to hold them accountable we're
chasing down leads we're reviewing
evidence
combing through digital media to
identify investigate and arrest
anyone who broke the law that day and
our greatest partner
in this investigation has been the
american people themselves
your constituents citizens from around
the country have sent us more than 270
000 digital media tips some have even
taken the painful step
of turning in their friends or their
family members
but with their help we've identified
hundreds of suspects
and opened hundreds of investigations in
all but one
of our 56 field offices and of those
identified we've arrested
already more than 270 individuals to
date
over 300 when you include the ones of
our partners
with more subjects being identified and
charged just about
every single day the fbi is committed
to seeing this through no matter how
many people it takes or how long
or the resources we need to get it done
because
as citizens in a sense we're all victims
of the january sixth assault
and the american people deserve nothing
less
unfortunately as you noted mr chairman
january 6th
was not an isolated event the problem of
domestic terrorism has been
metastasizing across the country for
a long time now and it's not going away
anytime soon
at the fbi we've been sounding the alarm
on it for a number of years now
i've been sounding the alarm about
domestic terrorism since i think just
about my first month on the job when i
first started appearing up on the hill
and i've spoken about it maybe a dozen
different congressional
hearings so whenever we've had the
chance we've tried to emphasize that
this
is a top concern and remains so for the
fbi
in fact in fact we viewed it as such a
critical threat
that back in june of 2019
under my leadership we elevated racially
and ethnically motivated violent
extremism to our highest
threat priority on the same level with
isis
and homegrown violent extremists where
it remains
to this day now i'm sure we're going to
cover a lot of ground
today but let me make one thing clear
the fbi will not tolerate
agitators and extremists who plan
or commit violence period
and that goes for a violent extremist of
any stripe
as i've said many times we do not
investigate ideology
but we focus on acts of violence and
violations of federal law and when we
see those
when we see those we will bring to bear
the full weight
of our resources our experience and our
partnerships
and when domestic violence extremists
use explosive devices
when they attack government facilities
and businesses when they assault
law enforcement officers when they use
violence to interfere with the lawful
operation
of our government they should expect the
fbi to come knocking on their door no
matter where they try to run
now of course these are not the only
issues the fbi's focus on every day and
as i hope we'll discuss in more detail
this morning we confront a wide variety
of threats in countless other forms
like the solar winds intrusions which
we're working to investigate and counter
with our intelligence
law enforcement and private sector
partners both here
and abroad not to mention a huge range
of
other cyber threats from nation states
criminals
and toxic combinations of the two
like the vast unrelenting
counterintelligence threat from china
and of course the alarming threat of
violence towards law enforcement
officers
a threat that's especially close to home
here in the capitol
the attack on january 6 not only
resulted in the injuries of over 100 law
enforcement officers but also the tragic
death
of u.s capitol police officer brian
siknik in the line of duty
the threat of violence to law
enforcement is also deeply personal
for us at the fbi just one month ago
today
two of our special agents laura
schwartzenberger
and dan alfin were tragically killed in
the line of duty
and four more of our asians shot or
wounded all while serving a search
warrant and i can tell you
that there is nothing nothing
more devastating more more heartbreaking
than the loss
of our own the loss of two special
agents who not only bravely did
what i consider one of the hardest jobs
in the fbi investigating crimes against
children
but who were also each parents of young
children themselves
of their own a wife
a husband and cherished members of their
communities
and i know a number of members of
congress including a number
on this committee reached out and
offered their condolences
and offerings of support and i want you
to know how much that means to the fbi
how much it means to me personally
special agents
laura schwarzenberger and dan alfin
sacrificed their lives that day
like far too many of our law enforcement
brethren
also killed in the line of duty their
ultimate sacrifice was not in vain
it was to protect the american peoples
to protect
each of us and it's why no matter what
comes our way
our work to safeguard the rule of law to
protect the american people and to
uphold the constitution
goes on and will never stop
thank you for the opportunity to speak
with you today i look forward
to answering the questions thanks
director we'll have
seven minute rounds for the members to
ask questions
uh let me start and as you said at the
outset there
we could spend the better part of a day
or beyond that with all the topics of
importance involved in the fbi but i
really have to stay with the january 6
situation there's a lot of confusion
about the planning and coordination by
federal state and local law enforcement
agencies in the days leading up to the
attack on the capitol
i was surprised to learn the fbi did not
issue
a threat assessment before january 6th
especially because the fbi's norfolk
virginia field office
had uncovered specific threats against
members of congress
maps of the tunnel system under the
capitol complex
and places to meet before traveling
together to washington
i was also surprised to hear acting dc
metropolitan police department chief
robert conte
say that his information was only
conveyed to the mpd
in an email at 7 pm the night before
january 6. chief conte acknowledged that
the information was raw
intelligence but said he would think
quote something as violent as an
insurrection at the capitol would
warrant a phone call or something
close quote so it comes down to the
basic question of what the fbi knew
when they knew it whether they shared it
why this didn't rise to the level of a
threat assessment
so mr chairman i welcome the question um
you touched on a number of points there
so first let me say that we
were in the period up leading up to
january 6
tracking the large amount of information
about large numbers of people coming to
participate in protests
and about the potential for violence the
one specific piece of information that
you refer to the information from our
norfolk field office has gotten a lot of
attention
so this was a what's called a
situational information report
was prepared by our norfolk field office
specifically for dissemination it was
as you noted raw unverified
uncorroborated information
that had been posted online and my
understanding
was that that information was quickly
as in within an hour uh disseminated and
communicated with our partners including
the u.s capitol police
including metropd in not one not two but
three different ways
when can you be more specific three
different ways so first
there was uh an email as you said to our
joint terrorism task force which
includes the joint terrorism task force
includes task force officers
specifically selected by their chiefs
who participate on the joint terrorism
task force is for the very reason to be
that that chiefs that department's eyes
and ears
uh so that they get the information real
time their departments do so that's the
first piece
second in addition to the email
verbally through the command post
briefing that we had because we had
stood up command post both in the
washington field office and
at headquarters and those command posts
included again
representatives of the of the relevant
agencies
capitol police mpd etc verbally the same
information was walked through
again and third in addition to the email
in addition to the verbal briefing at
the command post
there was the information was posted on
what we call leap which is a law
enforcement portal
which is made available to law
enforcement not just here in the
national capital region
but all around the country now again the
information was raw
it was unverified in a perfect world we
would have taken longer to be able to
figure out whether it was reliable
but we made the judgment uh our folks
made the judgment
uh to get that information to the
relevant people as quickly as possible
like i said three different ways in
order to leave as little as possible to
chance now i didn't see the report
myself
even until after the sixth but but the
way in which it handled at least as i
understand it
strikes me as consistent with our normal
process
director i was surprised to see that
reporting
that dozens of individuals on the
terrorist screening database
also known as the terrorist watch list
traveled to d.c in the days leading up
to the attack
i would have expected the fbi's
terrorist screening center to be aware
of air travel by watch listed
individuals to the
washington dc area did the tsc notice an
uptick in travel by watch-listed
individuals before january 6 if yes what
steps did they take
or did the fbi take in more general
terms to make sure other departments and
agencies knew these dangerous or
individuals were on their way to the
capitol
so when it comes to the the watch list i
think there's a couple things i could
say
uh here today so one is i do know that
in a number of instances
there were individuals on whom we had
previously predicated investigations
that we saw getting ready to potentially
travel
these are not large numbers but a
handful of people
and in those instances in a number of
instances we had agents
in their home states or home cities
approach those individuals
interview them even if we didn't have a
basis to charge somebody it dissuaded a
number of those people from traveling
i guess the second thing i would say is
that sometimes there's a little
confusion on the whole watch listing
concept there's a true
no-fly list which is what applies to
individuals who
under the rules provide a threat to
aviation itself
and then there's what we sometimes refer
to as selectees which are individuals
that can't necessarily be
barred in the same way from traveling
but uh in which there's notice
given to the agents investigating those
individuals and that
information is then passed on so in
those in a number of instances that
that happened uh in the period leading
up to the six i don't have numbers for
you though
i just have a minute left but i want to
address what i consider the next big lie
after the lie that the president really
won on november third president trump
the next big lie appears to be the
argument that somehow or another
those were not trump supporters who
invaded the capital
it was it made the rounds on the
internet
right before they came into the building
and has been gaining momentum
ever since i'd like to ask you directory
do you agree that the capital attack
involved white supremacists and other
violent extremists
uh certainly the capital attack
involved violent extremists as i said we
the fbi consider this a form of domestic
terrorism uh it included a variety of
backgrounds
certainly there were quite a number
we're seeing quite a number as we're
building out the cases on the
individuals we've arrested
for the violence quite a number who we
would call sort of militia violent
extremists
so we've got a number who self-identify
with you know the proud boys or the oath
keepers
things like that we also have a couple
of instances
where we've already identified
individuals involved in the criminal
behavior
who uh we would put in the racially
motivated
violent extremists who advocate for what
you would call for white supremacy so
they've been some of those individuals
as well
one of the things that's happening as
part of this is that as we build out
the cases on individuals when we arrest
them for the violence we're
getting a richer and richer
understanding of different people's
motivations
but certainly as i said militia violent
extremism some instances
of racially motivated violent extremism
specifically advocating for the superior
of the white race based on your
investigation so far do you have any
evidence that the capital attack
was organized by quote fake trump
protesters
we have not seen evidence of that at
this stage certainly
thank you senator grassley yeah
we all want to know what happened to
officer brian sicknick
tragic death as a result of that january
6 assault
there's been conflicting reports about
his cause of death
have you determined the exact cause of
death
and is there a homicide investigation
uh so i'll take the last part of your
question first there is an ongoing
investigation into his death
um i have to be careful at this age
because it's ongoing
not to get out in front of it but i
certainly understand
and respect and appreciate the the keen
interest
in what happened to him after all he was
here protecting all of you
and as soon as there are information
that we can appropriately share
we want to be able to do that but at the
moment the investigation is still
ongoing
so does that mean since the
investigation going on
you have not determined the exact cause
of the death
that means we can't yet disclose a cause
of death
at this stage but you have determined
the cause of that i didn't say that
we're not at a point where we can
disclose
uh or confirm the cause of death uh it's
important for
the committee to fully understand the
fbi's caseload
regarding domestic extreme ism cases
i have a series of data-driven
and data-centered questions for you that
i'll give
a list of these in sequence i'd prefer
the answers
now but if you don't have them i'll
accept those answers
after the hearing as long as you commit
to do so
so this is a series of questions
what percentage of your investigation
regarding january 6
are predicated as racially motivated
violence
extremists or white supremacists
originated individuals secondly
what percentage of our other extremist
ideologies for domestic violence
extremists homegrown violence
extremists and international extremists
how many total fbi investigations are
ongoing
and of that figure one how many are
motivated by
jihadist ideology how many are motivated
by white supremacy ideology
and how many are motivated by left-wing
anarchist
ideologies we need data and i hope you
see our need for this data so
can you answer those now or do you want
to get back in writing
uh well i will certainly get back to i'm
aware that uh
that we've gotten a letter that goes
through in quite detail
a number of specific data requests uh
and we're working on that
uh response as we speak there are
probably some things i could say
uh sitting here right now uh as i said
to the chairman
although i don't have the percentage for
you uh the
uh attackers on january 6th
included a number and the number keeps
growing as we build out our
investigations of what we would call
militia violent extremism
and we have had some uh already arrested
who
we would put in the category of racially
motivated vine extremism
white as well
those would be the categories so far
that we're seeing as far as january 6.
now looking back bigger picture because
i think the rest of your question
goes more to our caseload overall
i could say a number of things on that
in terms
of domestic violent extremism
domestic terrorism that number is now
has grown steadily on my watch
so i've we've increased the number of
domestic terrorism investigations
from around a thousand or so when i got
here
to up to about 1400 at the end of last
year
to about 2 000 now that's domestic
terrorism overall
when it comes to racially motivated
violent extremism that number again
number of investigations and number of
arrests
has grown significantly on my watch
uh and the number of arrests for example
of racially motivated violent extremists
who are what you would categorize as
white supremacists last year was almost
triple the number it was in my first
year as director
uh and when it comes to anarchist
violent extremists which is another
category that you asked about
that number has also grown over the
course uh
of my tenure last year i think we had
more arrests
of anarchist violent extremists than in
the prior three years combined
can i stop you there because you've done
a good job of giving
overall view and i assume in writing we
can get specific
answers and the numbers are very
important data is very important
former acting dhs
secretary wolf has stated quote
or not quote that the lack of visibility
into the anarchist
extremist movement may have caused the
federal government to be
under prepared for the riots this summer
former attorney general barr stated that
the fbi
has robust programs for white supremacy
and militia extremism but is
significantly weaker
anarchic extremism program so
unless you disagree with wolf or barr
how do you plan to make your left wing
anarchist extremism program as robust
as your white supremacy and malicious
extremism program
well i think there's a that's a long and
complicated question to answer in a
sense but i'll give you a few things for
right now
and one is i think as with any domestic
terrorism threat or frankly any
counter-terrorism threat more broadly
we're always looking to develop more and
better sources
so we get more visibility insight into
the plans and intentions tactics
procedures etc of any group of violent
extremists
another is to get better at learning how
to uh
to navigate around some of the
operational tradecraft that they use uh
so the more times the more arrests we
see and this is relevant both for the
anarchist violent extremists and for the
racially motivated by extremists for
example the more of the arrests that you
see
well that's obviously good news for
everybody that we're arresting people
who need to be arrested
there's a whole other part of that
that's really important that i want to
emphasize which is the more arrests we
make
the more from those cases we learn about
who else their contacts are what their
tactics are what their strategies are
etcetera and that makes
us smarter and better able to get in
front of the threat
going forward mr chairman can i ask one
very short question that i think will
give a short answer and then i'll submit
questions in writing if we don't have a
second round
why hasn't the fbi produced the january
5th
2021 norfolk memo to congress
uh so that information is law
enforcement sensitive
i'm aware of the interest and i think
part of the reason had been withheld
in consultation with the department had
been the ongoing investigations that we
have
but i certainly understand the interest
and i can commit to
that i will get with my staff and see if
we can make that available
okay thank you senator leahy by remote
am i unmuted now mr chairman
yes you are thank you uh director ray
thank you for
for being here i i don't envy you your
uh
job at all it uh
uh you know for those of us been here a
long time we've seen the changes
dramatic changes that go on
in what you face you've always spoken
about
the truth about the threat of domestic
terrorism and i i know that sometimes
it's been politically difficult to do so
you have to deal with reality you can't
deal with the politics so
i'll ask you a few quick questions begin
with do you stand by your previous
testimony that white supremacist
extremism
is the dominant most persistent
source of domestic terrorism threats we
face today
sorry i couldn't hear the last part of
the question which i think may be the
key parts i just want to make sure
do you stand by your you stand by your
previous testimony
the white supremacist extremism
is a dominant most persistent source
of domestic terrorism threats we face
today
i would certainly say as i think i've
said consistently in the past
that racially motivated violent
extremism specifically
of the sort that advocates for the
superiority of the white race
is a persistent evolving threat it's the
biggest chunk of our racially motivated
violent extremism cases for sure
uh and and racing motivate violent
extremism is the biggest chunk of our
domestic terrorism
portfolio if you will overall i will
also say that same group of people we're
talking about
have been responsible for uh the most
lethal attacks uh
over the last uh say decade
and when i look at what happened on
january 6
it appears that right wing
white supremacist groups played an
instrumental role
in the violent assault is that your
conclusion also
well uh let me answer that this way i
think we're basically saying the same
thing
we don't tend to think we at the fbi
don't tend to think of violent extremism
in terms of right left
you know that's not a uh a spectrum that
we
look at what i would say is that
it is clear as i think i said to
chairman durbin that
a large and growing number of the people
that we have arrested so far
in the uh in connection with the sixth
are what we would call militia violent
extremism
uh militia violent extremists and then
there have been some uh
already that have emerged who i would
have put in the racially motivated bond
extremist bucket
again advocating for the spirit of the
white race
and i understand from your testimony
previously that
you did not see antifa or
left-wing groups playing a significant
role
in the january sixth interaction
certainly while we're equal opportunity
and looking for
violent extremism of any uh of any
ideology
we have not to date seeing any evidence
of
of anarchist violent extremists or or
people subscribing to antifa
uh in connection with the sixth that
doesn't mean we're not looking and we'll
continue to look but
at the moment we have not seen that
so what you do is you uh look as
somebody in law enforcement assured you
look at where the crime
was and who committed it and you go
after that
not from some kind of political vendetta
but
you committed the crime we'll go after
you is that uh
too simplistic a way of stating it no no
not simplistic at all and and i think
a very very important point that you're
making there and something that's very
important to us at the fbi
we focus on the violence and the
violations of federal law
uh and then the ideology comes into it
as a
uh a further piece of the puzzle as we
build out the case
uh but our focus is on the violence we
don't care what ideology motivates
somebody as judge garland i think
himself
said uh just last week we don't care
whether it's left right
up down diagonal or any other way if the
ideology is motivating violence and it
violates federal law we're coming after
it
well i know you're going to come before
our appropriations committee
uh senator durbin higher on that and
others for a
a classified briefing and so i won't go
into some of the classified parts
but we are going to talk to you and and
i certainly
chair that committee very interested
in resources you got a finite number of
resources
and you have infinite number of problems
so you have to prioritize them
i had heard reports that the previous
administration diverted
fbi resources away from countering
white supremacist violence toward
objectively lesser threat of left-wing
violence
were you directed at all to shift
resources away from right-wing
extremists
we did not receive direction to nor did
we
separate or divert resources away from
tackling racially motivated violent
extremism
white over to anarchist violent
extremism
or anything along those lines in fact as
i've said we
i elevated racially motivate violent
extremism
the vast majority which is of what you
would call white supremacist violence
uh to our highest threat priority where
it has stayed and that drives resources
that drives the collection requirements
for
all of our field offices and
i think the results speak for themselves
we have significantly grown the number
of investigations
and arrests in the category that you're
asking about
it was up to about 1400 by the end of
last year and it's up to about 2 000
now which is doubled where it was at the
pace when i started this job
well that's what i would expect you to
go go where the crimes are and
go after it but we've seen a lot of
hate crime certainly uh concerns of
the hate crimes against asian americans
i was
the lead co-sponsor of the matthew
shepard hate crimes prevention
but now when we see the the increases
a recent fbi report indicates that 87
of law enforcement agencies
participating in the fbi's hate crime
data collection
have reported zero hate crime incidents
within their jurisdictions
do you think that's accurate
well certainly we are constantly trying
to improve
the quality uh and quantity of reporting
on hate crimes i think we know that
historically hate crimes are under
reported
having said that um it's not necessarily
the case that every department
is out there in the country is going to
have had a hate crime
in its jurisdiction in the course of any
given year
so uh we focus a little bit less on
whether
the percentage of departments that
report it we do want
the percentage of departments who are
cooperating and voluntarily responding
to go up
and we focus more on whether or not the
the growth and the number of hate crimes
reported overall
uh seems to be building or not certainly
i have other questions for the market
but you've testified before about a
fusion
cell i developed to address both hate
crimes and domestic terrorism
has that been helpful it has uh so what
you're referring to is something that i
put in place
i guess about 18 months maybe two years
ago
i created a domestic terrorism hate
crimes fusion cell
which brought together because a lot of
these crimes could fit either into a
domestic terrorism bucket or a hate
crimes bucket
and what i was worried about was making
sure that within the fbi we didn't have
a left-hand right-hand problem
and so we brought together people
focusing on both into a single fusion
cell
with the goal of trying to be proactive
uh
against some of the threats that are
coming and one example that i'll cite
that we're particularly pleased with
which i think is a
an indication of the success the cell is
having as we were able to get in front
of and prevent
an attempted uh i think explosives
attack on the synagogue
in colorado uh and
that i think is largely a credit to uh
the fusion cell which
was able to kind of help us figure out
how to get in front of those kinds of
attacks
thank you senator leahy thank you thank
you mr chairman senator graham
uh thank you uh director ray i'm going
to try to look forward then we'll talk a
little bit about january the 6.
do you think the national guard presence
at the capitol at the level we have
today should continue
if so for how long
you know um senator i'm not sure that
i'm really the best equipped to evaluate
the national guard presence okay um fair
enough fair enough
um uh you are the best equipped to talk
about the capability of the fbi
um do you have enough people and
resources to deal with all the threats
we've been talking about this morning
well uh needless to say senator i i
welcome and appreciate the question
um everywhere i go someone has really
good ideas about things they think the
fbi should be doing more of
but i have not found very many people
with great ideas
at least responsible ideas of things the
fbi could be doing less of
and so our folks are are busting their
you know what's
to try to deal with all these threats we
we need more agents we need more
analysts
we need more data analytics etc let's
just stop there
because we need to learn as much as we
can from january the 6th
this is the 20th anniversary of 9 11.
are you concerned about
international tariffs paying us a visit
absolutely
okay are you concerned about the
interaction between international
terrorist and domestic terrorists
that's a growing phenomenon certainly
something we're watching with concern
one of my great concerns was that as
people float into the capitol with
backpacks on
you had no idea who who they were and
what they were carrying
so it'd been very easy for some
international terrorist group to
infiltrate this crowd do you agree with
that
i do think it would have been easy for
that to happen another i don't know that
we've
seen evidence that it did happen but
that's certainly one of the specific
things we're looking for
after the attack don't you think
international groups are seeing this is
a vulnerability in our system
i'm sorry i couldn't hear though
international terrorist groups may have
found a way
to get closer to the capital by
integrating themselves into domestic
political movements
well certainly we think the events on
january 6 have been
at a minimum an inspiration to a number
of of terrorist
um uh extremists out there and may even
have been worse than that so here's my
challenge to you
sit down and put pen to paper and in the
uh
think big not small what do you need
that you don't have
in terms of agents and resources
and put it to paper i'm on the
appropriations committee with senator
durbin
many of us here are i think we've got an
opportunity here to plus you up
is it fair to say that since 9 11
domestic terrorism has
exploded as a threat well it's certainly
grown dramatically
uh drunk uh grown dramatically which
takes resources to combat
is that correct yes has the fbi
draw grown dramatically since 9 11.
not as dramatically as the threat okay
so what i want you to do
is take the number of agents and
resources you had on 9 11
and tell us where you're at today and
make sure that we understand that the
threats you're facing are much greater
than there were 20 years ago
and challenge us to give you the
resources to meet those threats
uh back to january the sixth
is it fair to say as director of the fbi
you were not informed
of the raw intelligence coming from the
north office is that correct
not before january 6 okay so
this was an internet posting that
somebody
captured my understanding is that this
was
information posted online uh under a
moniker
or a pseudonym uh it was
unvetted uncorroborated information but
it was
and it was somewhat aspirational in
nature but it was concerning
it was concerning and was specific
enough that we
our folks in norfolk thought the need to
get it out even if we hadn't had a
chance to
to corroborate or vet it okay looking
back
what would you have done differently
with this information because this is a
hard one you get something on the
internet
that's concerning you don't know if it's
true or not you capture it
what are the lessons learned in terms of
how we could have acted better on that
information
i think we're may not the truthful
answer is we're still looking at that
you know this was you know i look at
intelligence both collection
analysis dissemination uh
we need to get better at collecting
obviously but the key part here was we
often don't have the luxury of time
to analyze this information before it
gets disseminated and in this instance
our folks
uh in norfolk and washington field made
the judgment that
and i think it was a reasonable judgment
to get the information
like i said in three different ways to
their partners even though
even though they didn't know whether it
was going to turn out to be accurate
play that out a bit let's say it made it
up to the top levels of the capitol
police
intelligence units to the head of the
capitol police force
given that raw intelligence what would
you expect them to have done differently
you know i really want to be careful not
to be an armchair quarterback
that's the problem because i don't know
how to answer that question myself
because you can capture stuff today that
will make foretell on an attack tomorrow
but how much
this is a problem i just don't want
people to run down the road a there's an
intel screen shot i mean there's a
screenshot on some computer somewhere we
need to turn the whole government upside
down it's just a
a tough situation uh is the proud boys
are there a domestic terrorist group
uh well i don't think we have treated
the proud boys itself
as a domestic terrorism group but we
certainly have what does it take to make
the list
well there is uh as you may know uh
senator
uh under federal law under u.s law there
is no
uh list of domestic terrorism
organizations the same way there is for
foreign terrorist organizations well
let's
let's think about that in the next 47
seconds
oath keepers are are they a domestic
terrorist organization
we again as with proud boys we have
individuals who
associate themselves with that a
domestic terrorist organization
same thing same same answer so why don't
we think about
how to gather better information and
expose some of these groups if they were
on a list would it make it easier for
you
i think the issue of whether or not to
designate or have a formal mechanism for
designating domestic terror
uh groups in the same way we do with say
al-qaeda or isis
i think there's reasonable debate about
whether or not it would really
advance kkk a domestic terrorist group
well there is no uh legal designation
for domestic terrorism my point is
i don't know if we should have one or
not but i think it's time to think about
it
thank you senator graham senator
feinstein
thanks very much uh mr chairman and
welcome
um last november the associated press
reported that hate crimes
rose to the highest level in more than a
decade
the ap also reported that the united
states recorded the most
hate-related killings since the fbi
began
collecting data in the 1980s
despite this finding only about 14
percent of the agencies
in the fbi hate crimes report
indicated that hate crimes occurred in
their jurisdictions
so here's the questions what actions are
you
taking to make it easier for local
agencies to collect
and report this data to the fbi
so i appreciate the question i as your
question references uh we do know that
there is a
phenomenon that i think is fairly widely
accepted of under-reporting of hate
crimes
and so even though the number of hate
crimes reported is continues to grow
we don't know whether that means the
number of hate crimes is growing or
whether the number of reports of it is
now starting to grow we are trying
to do a lot we do hundreds of these uh
outreach training etc of state and local
law enforcement to help them understand
better how to identify
uh and report hate crimes uh we also
have a manual that that we
put out that helps explain better how to
uh to identify that of course a lot of
times the offenses
that they're looking at under state and
local laws don't necessarily come with a
neat label
that says this is a hate crime on it and
so that's part of the challenge but
we're working with them to try to
improve awareness so that we can get
better reporting on the subject
well that's certainly appreciated um
i want to ask about the threat of
domestic terrorism by white supremacists
it isn't new but it's gained a lot of
attention
within intelligence circles in recent
years
and it's the biggest domestic terrorism
threat i
understand last year you testified
before the house armed
uh house homeland security committee
that quote
the most lethal of all domestic
extremists
since 2001 have been racially
and ethic ethnically motivated
similarly the former acting dhs
secretary
testified before the senate that quote
white supremacist
extremists from a lethality standpoint
over the last two years particularly
when you look at 2018 and 19
are the most precise persistent and
lethal threat
when we talk about domestic extremists
why is the threat of white supremacist
terrorism
so prevalent in this country
you know i think that's a uh some of
that is a sociological question that i'm
not sure that i'm really the right
person to
to address certainly uh as you say
it has been uh the biggest chunk
of our racially motivated violent
extremism
uh cases uh and itself the biggest chunk
of our domestic terrorism
caseload overall uh and the most
lethality over the last decade has been
from these same extremists
the things that drive these people um
you know i think range
uh one of the things that we struggle
with in particular is that more and more
the ideologies if you will that are
motivating some of these violent
extremists are less and less coherent
less and less linear less and less
easy to kind of pin down
in some cases it seems like people
coming up with their own sort of
customized belief systems a little bit
of this a little bit of that and they
put it together maybe combined with some
personal grievance of something that's
happened in their lives
and that drives them and so trying to
get your arms around that
uh is is a real challenge let me move on
there's been a spike in gun sales during
the pandemic
the new york times reports that
approximately 2 million
guns were purchased in march of 2020
that's the second highest month ever
according to a july politico article
there were eight hundred and twenty
three thousand
273 nix checks
in march of 2019 versus 1.4 million
in march of 2020.
so in march of 2020
nix blocked more than double
the amount of the year before a whopping
23
692 gun sales
in one year simply put
there's been a dramatic rise in gun
sales
that's likely going to require some
further action
what have you seen and what will the if
fbi be doing and or recommending
so in terms of what we're seeing because
we all share
the goal of trying to keep guns out of
the hands of those who are legally
prohibited from possessing them
which is of course the whole point of
why nix exists
last year as you say we've seen
a significant increase i think last time
i checked i think it was something like
of the top 10
[Music]
highest number of nix checks you know
per day or per week uh
ever were all last year uh you know
maybe seven of the top ten
ever last year so the numbers have been
uh
really significant during the course of
of 2020 and the pandemic
we have been trying very hard and i
think we've done a good job of staying
on top of the
the required pace that uh
that we have to keep up with to be able
to get that done which has been
had required being creative because of
covid and
teleworking and all the things that
we've had to kind of work around to keep
up with that
but it is a challenge and i think the
budget requests that we've had recently
have asked for more resources for nics
because we need to try to keep up
with that pace thank you
as early as december 29th the fbi warned
about the potential for armed
demonstrators
targeting legislators legislatures
the former chief of capitol police
as well as the house and senate
sergeants of arms
have testified that they did not see the
fbi's warning
on the eve of january 6 about
potential violence in the capital
when did you first receive intelligence
about the possibility
of an attack on the capital on january 6
and what happened to the process that
people weren't seeing
the warnings well senator i think
uh the the intelligence or the
information
you're asking about is the
much-discussed norfolk
uh sir or situational information report
i didn't see that report which was raw
unverified intelligence until
some number of days after the sixth but
again that raw
unverified information was passed
within i think 40 minutes to an hour
to our partners including the capitol
police including metro pd and not one
not two but three different ways
one email one verbal and one through the
law enforcement portal
as to why the information didn't flow to
all the people within the various
departments
that that they would prefer i i don't
have a good answer for that
i will tell you the capitol police and
metropd are terrific partners to the fbi
especially our washington field office
i'm grateful for their partnership and
and have nothing but
admiration for the hard work and courage
and professionalism of the men and women
who work in both
of those agencies thank you senator
thank you thank you for your good work
it's appreciated
senator cornyn director ray after
uh the events of 9 11 i think it was
admiral bobby inman who coined the
phrase a failure of imagination
we just couldn't conceive of the idea
that something
like what happened on 9 11 would occur
but that was a failure to imagine it
and it strikes me that the events of
january the 6th
share something in common with 9 11 in
the sense that
seemed like there was a failure of
imagination that's not to point the
finger
that he didn't want buddy to blame but
merely to try to describe
what i think may have occurred
so i think you've told us that these
extremists are not monolithic
is that correct that's correct well i
i've i've heard the
expression that here in washington
whoever has the best narrative
wins and so sometimes i think the
narrative
is created and then try to search for
facts that might bolster that
narrative but as you said the fact is
they're
these extremist groups are not
monolithic
so that's i think an important part of
understanding
the threat i've heard them described
some of
these folks described as white
supremacists
domestic terrorists insurrectionists
writers seditionists anarchists
the list goes on and on
but i note that you said there is no
federal crime um described as domestic
terrorism per se correct
that's correct and as i look at the
range of charges that the fbi and the
department of justice
have have made against the
people that have been investigated for
the events of january the 6th
i read a list of assaulting federal
officers
tampering with documents or proceedings
unlawful entry
disorderly conduct conspiracy
theft of government property do you
think the current
laws are adequate to deal with this
threat
it strikes me as these are these are a
lot of different tools that are
available but don't really get to the
whole
part of domestic terrorism
uh i guess i'd say a couple things in
response that it's of course
uh it's of course a very good question i
think number one our folks
uh which is one of the things i love
about the men and women of the fbi
have proven uh time and again that they
will work with the tools they have
uh and they are resourceful and
entrepreneurial
and we've had remarkably good success at
disrupting attacks
uh using the tools that we have
sometimes those tools and some of the
offenses that you listed off
have the virtue of being quite simple
and straightforward to prove and so
sometimes that's actually
a blessing but certainly i think
uh you would be hard-pressed to find any
fbi director that wouldn't welcome
more tools in the toolbox fair enough
well getting back to this narrative
about who was involved on january the
6th
there was a helpful report from the
george washington university
program on extremism that looked at
about
257 federal defendants
as a result of the events of january the
6th
they noted that 142 of those 257
defendants
they referred to as inspired believers
they said they were need they concluded
they were neither participants
in any violent extremist group
um nor connected with any individual
uh who stormed the capital um again
i guess bears out your conclusion your
statement that
this is not a monolithic group again so
i think you've touched on two very
important points there one is
uh both with domestic violent extremists
and frankly with what we call the
homegrown vile extremists
which are the jihadist inspired the
difference between
inspired terrorist attacks and
over here and domestic and sort of
directed or facilitated you know in a
more structured formal way
uh is something that i think a lot of
americans
struggle with understanding and more and
more the threat that we face
as a country is what i would call the
inspired attacks
they don't have formal membership in an
organization they don't have
clear command and control direction uh
in the way that say an al-qaeda sleeper
cell might might have
uh and that that's that much more
challenging to pursue a because there
are fewer dots to connect you know the
old expression about
dots to connect right uh b less time in
which to connect whatever dots there are
and then uh then you add into it c the
the sort of first amendment dimensions
of people's inspirations and ideology
and then the last point i would make uh
is that we have these as i said before
increasingly blended ideologies
uh so for example uh in senator
klobuchar state
in minnesota we had two individuals uh
who were
identified themselves as so-called
boogaloo boys
which people tend to put kind of in one
bucket and yet
what they ultimately were charged with
was trying to provide material support
as in weapons to hamas
and these are not things that neatly fit
together in anybody's
world view so it just illustrates one
example but it illustrates the challenge
uh that we're dealing with
it's the fbi's responsibility to deal
with counterintelligence investigations
correct yes
and these include things like active
measures
that we saw used for example in 2016
for example advertising on facebook two
competing groups to show up at the same
time and hoping that
conflict and and maybe even violence
would break out
um is it true that um
our foreign adversaries used the events
of night
of january the 6th as a field day
in terms of their attempt to establish
false personas fabricate stories on
social media platforms
with an intent to discredit the united
states and its institutions
uh certainly we have seen and i'll keep
it at
unclassified level in this setting but
uh foreign adversaries
a number of them uh leveraging the
events of january 6th
to amplify their own narratives to try
to push out propaganda
misinformation to try to in their view
accelerate
what they think of as the united states
has declined
thank you thank you senator cornyn
senator whitehouse
thank you uh director ray welcome um
before we get to the business of this
hearing we've got some
in fact a lot of um unfinished business
um do you know how many questions for
the record the fbi
failed to answer in the last four years
i do not
well i'll tell you there were nine
hearings in this committee
in which the fbi was a test uh a witness
and in seven of them the committee got
exactly zero
questions for the record
seven zero questions
can you explain that i cannot
uh i will do anything better with the
questions that we're getting right now
you've been asked questions for the
record are they going to go into the
same
whatever it was whole where questions
for the record go to die at the fbi
uh well senator first thing i would say
about questions for the record
uh is that as you may know there is a an
elaborate
interagency process that requires that
answers
uh that we provide which is immensely
convenient for the
executive branch but our questions don't
direct that interagency process do they
and that interagency process doesn't
respond to us in congress does
we it required to comply with the
interagency process to
to provide our responses to questions
for the record by having said that
having
what are you required to comply with
that interagency process
i i can't cite you the the reg or the
rule because it seems to me that when
the fbi wanted
to get information to this committee
particularly when it wanted to get
information to republican members of
this committee so they could investigate
your investigation of the trump-russia
connection that information got
right through to our republican
colleagues it didn't go
didn't seem to go through any
interagency process it wasn't delayed
what we seem to have is for
most of us this was bipartisan by the
way when i say we got zero
questions for the record answered from
those hearings i mean
zero questions of any member of this
committee not zero democratic
members answered okay so you've got this
basic highway for
responses to congress let me ask you
just a little sidebar you think congress
deserves responses to questions from
executive agencies
as part of our oversight responsibility
yes absolutely
okay good so we're at least over that
hurdle so we've run this
rigmarole with the interagency process
in which we don't get answers some of
these go back to 2017
by the way that's years
of not getting our questions answered
and then
when it's a question that's suddenly of
interest
to one party and to president trump
there seems to be a little side road
that gets built around the traffic jam
and stuff just flies right through so
please don't tell me about interagency
process when i've been sitting
in this committee watching fbi
information
get straight to this committee without
interagency process
what are we going to do about this is
this a problem
so senator let me say first uh as i said
that i absolutely agree with you that
congress needs answers to its questions
i am frustrated as well
at the process i have added more staff
and my understanding is that when it
comes to correspondence for example
which just doesn't require the same
interagency process that we have
significantly reduced
the backlog and the turnaround time but
there's no question in my mind
we had no question in my mind eight
letters go unanswered
the oldest one dated march of 2017.
so if you think your process is working
we're not seeing it on our end
well i will commit to you that i will do
what i can to improve the process
i am uh frustrated as you are
and we have obviously we need to get
better well i will commit to you
that i'm going to make sure that this
gets done
and if it means stopping nominees if it
means
doing whatever it takes to get through
this problem we're gonna get through
this problem
because it is just plain wrong for the
executive branch of government
in a separation of powers country
to refuse to answer questions of the
elected
representatives of the legislative
branch it's just wrong
and however many excuses and however
much rigmarole the executive branch may
set up
to slow down those answers i don't care
that's your executive branch rigmarole
that is not
a legitimate answer to a legislator's
question and i got stuff that's now
backed up for years
now the courts have said that they're
not they don't want to intervene in
enforcing our subpoenas
i'm not sure we can get subpoenas in a
50 50 committee but
assume we could the courts have said
they don't want to enforce it
so you guys can put our subpoenas in the
same file with our letters on our qfrs
and not answer them and then what
happens is the courts have said
the way we resolve this is we've got to
hit you legislatively
the court said we should hold up
appropriations
for the fbi and for executive agencies
that aren't responsive
that's our tool
your people do good work director ray i
don't think you want that to be our tool
but you can't be in a situation in which
you don't answer our questions
you create rigmarole log jams and when
there's a
political interest in getting
information out to the committee
suddenly none of that rigmarole pertains
suddenly everybody gets their hands on
all the information that they need
just as soon as they need it and by the
way i believe on a partisan basis
not shared with both sides of the
committee
so before we get to clearing up whatever
else we need to get cleared up
all the stuff that's backed up behind
our questions
we've got to get through the problem of
why you're not answering our questions
and we've got to clear that up and i
don't know how we clear that up
i think we cleared up mr chairman in a
bipartisan fashion because i think
both sides should get this
but this business of years going by
of hearings in which zero qfrs get
answered
and letters that get thrown off into the
don't care to don't care to answer that
one pile
woodrow wilson once said that the
oversight function the investigative
function of congress
is often to be preferred even to its
legislative function
got to get that back
and i'm going to find a way with this
committee and with you
to clear the backlogs i don't think you
think that i should
give up on questions because i've been
stonewalled for years if
i've asked them and they deserve answers
they should be answered is that correct
yes okay my time is up we'll leave it at
that
mr chairman if i just may add with your
indulgence
one point senator i commit to
working with you to try and see how we
can improve our responsiveness
and to getting you more of the
information you need the one thing i
will say is that i can assure you
that in terms of my responsiveness to
this committee to the members of this
committee
or to congress overall it is absolutely
not
speaking only for myself now on a
partisan basis
well you run an organization that seems
to have operated under very different
rules
and it was you running that organization
so let's not make these distinctions
right now
thank you senator senator lee thank you
mr chairman thanks director ray for
being here and for your service to our
country
like literally every other person in
this room like literally every
member of the united states senate i'm
anxious to see those who
committed unlawful violent acts on
january 6 brought to justice
i also believe that with this
circumstance like every other
circumstance we have to make sure that
the civil liberties of the american
people are protected
that we watch over them i've
heard a number of accounts of
individuals who were present in
washington dc
but never got anywhere near the capitol
uh or any violence
on january 6th who have inexplicably
been
contacted by the fbi uh uh
by agents who apparently were aware of
their presence
in washington dc that day with no other
explanation
perhaps other than the use of
geolocation data
are you geolocating people through the
fbi
based on where they were on january 6th
uh
i i think there may be some instances in
which geolocation has been an
investigative tool but i can't speak to
any specific situation what are you
using to do that what what's what's your
basis for authority
are using national security letters we
i don't believe that in any instance
we're using national security letters
for
investigation capital i don't believe
fisa is remotely implicated in our
investigation are you using
warrants predicated on probable cause
we certainly have executed a number of
warrants in the course of the
investigation of january 6.
all of our investigative work uh in
response to the capital has been
under the legal authorities that we have
uh in consultation with the department
and the prosecutors at the
no no i i understand that i'm just
trying to understand how you're getting
it so so is the fbi
accessing uh cell phone tower metadata
from telecommunications companies is
that where it's coming from
again i without knowing the specifics
without being able to drill into the
specifics it's hard for me to answer
your question in a way that i think you
are there instances in which you're
you're interviewing people based solely
on information derived from a
telecommunications provider
providing geo-location information
indicating that they were on or near
the national mall on january 6. with
respect senator
because this is a massive nationwide
investigation
involving thousands and thousands of
interviews it's very hard for me to
speak with any
absolute confidence as to whether
there's any interview
predicated on any one specific oh i
understand that i understand that
um and and i certainly wouldn't expect
you to be aware of every
circumstance i would though like to know
whether you're
doing that at all whether that is ever
at the basis for it i would appreciate
uh if you if you could answer that if
you're not aware of it right now that's
great but if you could let me know
sometime today or tomorrow that'd be
great i'm sure there's someone who can
provide a yes or no answer to that
question
over the years i've raised a number of
of questions and it's one of the things
that prompted my question here
about fisa and related questions
uh just about the collection of uh
uh metadata from communications
providers and so forth over the years
and
by over the years i mean literally over
the last 10 years the entire 10 years
i've served
as a member of this committee and as a
member of the united states senate i've
been told fairly consistent answers
under different fbi directors and
different
presidential administrations run by
different parties but the
most consistent theme in those answers
has been just trust us
don't worry we've got good people smart
people law abiding people who are
running this
and we've got procedural safeguards in
place
to prevent the type of abuse that you're
concerned about
uh now
inspector general horowitz issued a
report
uh in in 2019 or regarding crossfire
hurricane
and through a subsequent memorandum
dealing with woods file issues
uh that really helped prove my point
um at the time in response to those
concerns you issued statements
uh suggesting that you would take
concrete actions to
make sure that these things were changed
could you tell me what some of those
actions are have you taken the actions
you referred to in response
to horowitz's uh report and his
subsequent memo
on the woods file issues uh yes senator
i welcome the question
so so first off as you may know we
accepted
all of the findings and recommendations
in the inspector general's report
i ordered at the time over 40
corrective actions to go above and
beyond the recommendations of the
inspector jones report and those have
been implemented
those include everything from
strengthening our procedures to ensure
accuracy and completeness to make sure
the court gets all the information it's
supposed to
changes in our protocols for uh chs's
confidential human sources training
changes we we
i created a new office of internal audit
uh that's specifically focused on fisa
auditing
uh there's a whole number of things i'd
be happy to walk through but i i
recognize that uh
our time is limited so you tell me how
much i appreciate that
um and i appreciate anything that you've
done within the agency to do that
i hope you can understand uh my concern
which is that we've been told over and
over again we already have strong
procedures in place internally
those strong procedures apparently
haven't over the last 10 years proven
enough
so my view is that in addition to
anything that you may be doing that
that may well be helpful and i
appreciate anything that you're doing
that's helpful
we probably ought to have some statutory
restrictions as well
so that it's not the fbi and the fbi
alone uh
acting solely upon the fbi's internal
guidance documents from which the fbi
could have
of course choose to depart at any moment
i'd love to see reforms in this area
and in particular to protect the civil
liberties of the american people
um i think we need some reforms uh to
our domestic surveillance tools
including
things like fisa uh
that would apply to strengthening at the
amicus provisions
of the fisa court requiring the fbi to
disclose all material
exculpatory evidence uh that's presented
to the
fisa court no less important here
than in a uh an article three court
sitting in its capacity of uh
adjudicating criminal cases in fact if
anything it's more important here
because in the fisa context it's not
public
increasing the standard for warrants
under section 215
to require a probable cause
and requiring a probable cause warrant
to obtain internet search history
internet browsing history and
and geo location information are those
reforms that you'd be willing to support
well senator i'd be happy to uh to work
with you to provide sort of operational
assessment of the impact of different
legislative ideas
uh certainly we view our responsibility
as not just to protect the american
people but
also to uphold the constitution uh and
we say that every day in the fbi
certainly i would want to make sure that
any legislative
changes to fisa didn't have unintended
very damaging impact on everything from
our sharing of information with our
foreign partners our intelligence
committee partners
that we didn't elevate the standard in
fisa above the level of what we could
get for example in an ordinary criminal
case things like that but we'd be happy
to engage with you on the subject
mr chairman my time's expired can i uh
add one sentence to the end just to
complete the thought
thank you for your willingness there i i
this um
we have been told over the last 10 years
since i've been here
we will work with you we will work with
you
has translated into opposition from
inside the fbi
every single time we've tried to bring
about one of those reforms
every time as sure as the sun will come
up in the east tomorrow
we've been told by the fbi you can't do
that
don't worry we've got it with our own
internal controls
i hope you'll be sympathetic to me this
time around recognizing
that i've been told that over and over
and over again and we're not
going to accept that answer anymore
thank you
[Music]
thank you senator lee senator klobuchar
thank you very much uh mr chair
uh welcome director ray uh you and i
have talked many times and i appreciate
the work of your agents in minnesota
whether it's
investigating uh buildings that have
been attacked and burned or whether it
is the work that
your agents did in investigating the
bombing of a mosque in minnesota where
you
which resulted in indictments and
conviction so i thank you for that
so last week i shared a joint hearing of
the rules and homeland security
committees
on what happened on january 6 we're
having another joint hearing with
homeland security
tomorrow several members of this
committee participated
in that and i want to start out with
something
that became an issue in the hearing
really because of one member's questions
our witnesses all agreed that there is
now clear evidence that supports the
conclusion
uh that this insurrection was planned
and a coordinated
attack in the capital um that white
supremacists and extremist groups were
involved
and that what happened would have been
much more dangerous if not
for the brave actions of law enforcement
would you agree with that
uh certainly there were aspects of it
that were planned and coordinated
but yes well there was a i just noted
that just today
reporting in the washington post that on
monday a
complaint was filed against a member of
the proud boys in washington state
where federal prosecutors alleged uh
that
in fact they had there were plans made
for many different entries into the
capital
is that correct yes there have been
a growing number of charges as we
continue to build out
the investigation either individuals who
are now starting to get arrested
that involving charges that involve more
things like planning and coordination or
in some instances individuals who were
charged with more simple offenses but
now we're superseding
as we build out more of an understanding
of what people were involved in and
there were clearly
some individuals involved which i would
consider the most
dangerous most serious cases among the
group
who did have uh plans and intentions and
some level of coordination and i think
you've arrested now
20 members of that group or file is that
right
i don't i don't know the number off top
of my head well yeah and so what i was
thinking when senator graham was talking
is that if
and they show up we now know in this
complaint with encrypted two-way
chinese radios in military gear um
that um you must there must be moments
where you think if we would have known
uh if we could have uh infiltrated this
group or found out what they were doing
and that
do you you have those moments absolutely
i will tell you senator
uh this is this is something i feel
passionately about
uh that anytime there's an attack our
standard at the fbi is we aim to bat a
thousand
right and we aim to thwart every attack
that's out there
so anytime there's an attack especially
one that's this horrific that strikes
right at the heart
of our system of government right at the
time transfer of power is being
discussed
you can be darn tootin that we are
focused very very hard on how can we get
better sources better information better
analysis
so we can make sure that something like
what happened on january 6
never happens again okay
so we've there's been a lot of
discussion about this norfolk memo
that arrived as you noted with
key people in the capitol police and
others the night before
they testified last week the chief that
he didn't even know about it until the
few days before our hearing um and in
fact
um while there may be some that
downplays that intelligence i will know
while we don't have the memo
publicly that in that memo they were
statements that congress needs to hear
the glass breaking doors being kicked
out
blood being spilled we get our president
or we die
go there ready for war some of the
specific
calls for violence that we know were
posted at that time we know that
president trump had called on people to
go there on january 6 we know that he
told them
to go wild we know that in that memo
there was discussions of
as reported in those perimeter maps
bringing back the wounded
and to me it just seems like it's beyond
aspirational in nature that it seems
like some of these
reports that we now know exist out there
were
specific in terms of these plans that
were going on
and um i'm just one of my questions that
we will
continue to be asking as part of this
investigation we're doing
with the rules committee and homeland
security is
um how can we change this so this never
happens again so these types of threats
and these this type of information gets
to the right people
and do you have any response on that
well as i said in
in connection with the particular report
uh that you're referring to the norfolk
sir as they call it um
we did communicate that information
in a timely fashion to the capitol
police and mpd
in not one not two but three different
ways do you think it's enough just to
send an email well it's more than just
an email
right so first off the email itself
went to i think there are maybe as many
as five capital police task force
officers on the joint terrorism task
force and the whole point of the joint
terrorism task force
is for the chosen representatives
of the partner agency to be
there in the loop real time so that
everybody's got the same information so
that each agency can use that
information to do what it needs to do
but in addition to the email so belton
suspenders
it was verbally briefed uh and i don't
it's hard sometimes for members of
congress to picture what these command
post briefings are like but picture
the command post that we had stood up at
the washington field office
representatives of all these agencies in
the room
people are coming up to the microphone
one at a time saying okay now we're
tracking this we're seeing this we don't
know if it's real or not but here's what
we're seeing and everybody's taking
notes and the whole idea
is they're supposed to go back and pass
it up their chain of command and then
third in addition to that it was put
into the leap the law enforcement portal
to make sure everybody got it so
explain that having said that i do not
consider what happened on january 6th
to be an acceptable result and that's
why we're looking so hard at figuring
how can the process be improved right
and some of this
of course is the whole structure we have
with this
capitol police board uh that somehow the
um the chief uh was still
calling all the insurrection was going
on these two sergeant-of-arms to try to
get permission to get the national guard
um and this clearly there has to be some
major changes to what's going on here i
acknowledge that and i'm going to push
for them
um but there still to me seems like they
rely on
the fbi and other federal agencies to
get information
and we know that the new york police
department sent intelligence reports
to them to the capitol police that's on
them
and the fbi's washington field office in
late december indicating there'd be
violence
on uh january 6. any comments on that
so well i'm not familiar with the
specific nypd
uh product you're referring to i will
tell you that we the fbi
over the course of 2020 put out a number
of intelligence products specifically
warning about
domestic violent extremism including
specifically warning about it in
connection with the election
including specifically warning about
that threat
in relation to the election continuing
past election day itself
and up through the inauguration and
including a product that i think we put
out with dhs
in december of 2020. so we we have
trying to push out information
i am reluctant to armchair quarterback
anyone else
in their jobs i can tell you we at the
fbi are determined to do our part
our part to make sure that what happened
on january 6 doesn't happen again
we find it personally infuriating
anytime
we're not able as i said to bat a
thousand and we're going to keep working
to get better
thank you and i i will say that the work
you've done on your
your agents have done in investigating
these cases
uh to me that is very helpful uh to get
those arrests out there and those
prosecutions
uh not only because people should be
brought to justice but it
uh to me is a major deterrent for people
doing this again
thank you thank you senator klobuchar
senator cruz
thank you mr chairman director ray
welcome thank you for your service and
thank you for the
heroic service of the men and women at
the fbi
um congress has now heard from
numerous law enforcement uh officials
that
there is significant evidence that the
january 6th attack on the capitol was
premeditated planned and coordinated and
you just
had an exchange with senator klobuchar
where you
if i understood you correctly expressed
the fbi's view that it was indeed
planned and coordinated
uh i recognize this as an ongoing
investigation
and that you're still learning the
details but at this point
what do we know about the planning and
coordination
that that occurred surrounding the
january 6th
attack so uh
i guess let me step back and say first
thing is um
there are sort of three groups of people
involved in january sixth
the first group the largest group the
group we need to spend the least time
talking about
is peaceful maybe rowdy protesters but
who weren't violating the law
then there's a second group think of a
reverse pyramid a second group
that is people who may have come
intending to just be part of peaceful
protest but either swept up in in the
motive or emotion or whatever
uh engaged in kind of low-level criminal
behavior trespass say on the capitol
grounds but not breaching the building
still criminal conduct still needs to be
addressed more
on the fly in the moment opportunistic
the third group
the smallest group numerically but by
far and away the most serious group
are those who uh who breached the
capitol grounds who engaged in violence
against law enforcement who attempted to
disrupt
the members of congress in the conduct
of their constitutional responsibilities
and of those
some of those people clearly came to
washington
we now know uh with with plans and
intentions to engage in the worst kind
of violence we would consider domestic
terrorism and so some of that
coordination
appears to have been coordinated travel
coordinated meeting up
coordinated in terms of fear that might
be wearing or bringing with them that
kind of thing
again ongoing obviously ongoing much
more to come but
you know often in an investigation
[Music]
law enforcement follows the money is
there evidence at this point of
coordinated funding prior to january 6
providing military equipment providing
communications equipment
or the like certainly that's a topic
that we're looking at
i don't know that there's anything i can
say right now in terms of funding or
coordinated funding
um there's been considerable discussion
at this hearing also about the
the norfolk report at the time
how credible and and reliable did the
fbi consider the norfolk report as an
actionable piece of intelligence uh my
senator my understanding is that our
folks at the time
viewed it as raw unverified and
therefore
of unknown reliability information but
because of the level of detail that was
in it um and some of this is art not
science unfortunately in the world of
intelligence the judgment was uh
that given the press of time given the
specificity
in it even though it sounded somewhat
aspirational in nature
and was unverified the smartest thing to
do the most prudent thing to do was just
to push it
to the people who needed to get it and
as i said that happened three different
ways
um you had a conversation with senator
grassley about
the the death of officer signing and
there obviously is
considerable interest and concern in
the senate and across the country as uh
as to the circumstances of officer
sicknick's death there have been
conflicting reports
about the circumstances of his death you
told senator grassley the fbi at this
point
is not in a position to confirm a cause
of death
uh is there any information that the fbi
can share with the american people about
what we know of the circumstances
surrounding his tragic death
uh although i i'm i certainly
understand and appreciate the keen
interest in it for all the reasons we've
discussed
at the moment other than to say the
capitol police has of course
categorized it i think appropriately as
a line of duty death
there's nothing really that i can share
right now certainly i understand why
it's very much top of mind for people
and i think it speaks well of the
members of congress that they're so
interested in somebody who's
lost his life protecting all of you so
soon as we're in a position
when the investigation has gotten to a
stage where we can share information
we want to be able to do that now let's
talk
more broadly about domestic terrorism
because
riot on january 6 didn't occur
come out of nowhere and last year the
department of justice created a task
force
to investigate and understand the growth
of political violence
the memo creating the task force states
amid peaceful demonstrations protected
by the first amendment we have seen
anti-government extremists engage in
indefensible acts of violence designed
to undermine public order
among other lawless conduct these
extremists have violently attacked
police officers and other government
officials
destroyed public and private property
and threatened
innocent people is that task force still
operating
i know the work that the task force
began is still ongoing
in the past year we have seen massive
rioting and violence
as extremists many of them leftist
extremists took to the streets across
the country
in just two weeks at the end of may in
early june
over 700 law enforcement officers were
injured
looking at all of 2020 over 14
000 people have been arrested in 49
cities and at least 25 people have died
the violence
and it's estimated the property damages
from these riots could exceed 2 billion
what is the fbi doing to counter this
this
ongoing pattern of domestic terrorism
so senator uh certainly we
tried to respond aggressively with our
partners to
the domestic violent extremism that we
saw playing out in streets all across
the country this summer
most of that activity a lot of that
activity
i would say fell in what we would
categorize as anti-government
anti-authority violent extremism
some of it is anarchist violent
extremism some of it is militia violent
extremism some of it might even be
sovereign citizen
violent extremism but we saw a huge
uptick
in violent extremism in that broad
bucket over the course of last year
and so we're trying to be aggressive
with the tools that we have in terms of
the charges we're bringing we're trying
to
as we talked about frankly in connection
with january 6
same thing for the summer we're trying
to look at sources of funding planning
coordination
trying to learn more about tradecraft
and tactics and things like that so that
we can be better prepared to prevent it
and feed information to our state local
partners so they can be better prepared
to prevent it
as as i think i said to to senator
grassley
last year we had three times
the number of anarchist violent
extremist arrests
from say prior year i think it was
certainly
more last year than the prior three
years combined
we did see last year as senator graston
noted in his
opening comments the first
murder by an anarchist violent extremist
last year in quite some time certainly
which was the individual who in portland
killed a supporter of an opposing
viewpoint and then the
the individual in question the violent
extremist was himself
killed in a in a shootout as the
marshals were trying to
apprehend him thank you
senator coons and thank you chairman
durbin director ray
welcome thank you for your service and
your testimony today and let me
join uh with my colleagues in conveying
our condolences
on the line of duty deaths of special
special agents daniel alfin and
laura schwarzenberger um it has been a
long time since there's been a special
agent line of duty death but every loss
of life
by those who are serving us and
protecting us is too many and
we join in grieving their loss and hope
you'll convey that to their families
but our purpose here today is to focus
principally on what happened
in this complex in this building in the
capitol on january 6.
charleston charlottesville pittsburgh el
paso
kenosha and right here in the u.s
capitol
these are just some of the recent
examples where far-right extremists and
white supremacists have
terrorized this country their fellow
citizens and murdered individuals
we all condem violence by anyone of any
political persuasion but we have to be
honest about the significant threats
we face and that's the only way we can
work together to take steps to confront
them
i think it's critical to that process
for us to uncover the real facts
of what happened and given some of the
misinformation being spread by some
colleagues i just would appreciate your
redressing
re-addressing a couple of questions
can you speak with clarity about what we
know
about the january 6 the riot here at the
capitol you've said
there have been i think 280 arrests so
far
um has there so far been any evidence
that the january 6th
riot here the insurrection was organized
by people
simply posing as supporters of president
trump
we have not seen any evidence of that uh
certainly
is there any evidence at all that it was
organized or planned or carried out by
groups like
antifa or black lives matter we have not
seen ebony have any evidence to that
effect
thus far in the investment and is there
any doubt that the people who stormed
the capital included
white supremacists and other far-right
extremist organizations
uh there's no doubt that it included uh
individuals that we would call militia
violent extremists
uh and then in some instances
individuals that were racially motivated
violent extremists
who advocate for you know the
superiority of the white race but the
militia violent extremist is probably at
the moment
uh trending the biggest bucket
if you will well you face challenges we
as a nation
face challenges with extremists of all
stripes types backgrounds
motivations as the new chair of the
subcommittee on privacy and technology
and law i'm concerned about how
extremists have used social media
platforms to organize and incite
violence
and in some ways about how social media
platforms work
to accentuate or accelerate those
who have extreme views and to
potentially radicalize those
who who don't hold those views i led a
letter with 14 colleagues
last november to facebook raising
concerns about the adequacy of their
enforcement of their own
policies against violence and incitement
um can you speak to the extent to which
the january 6th
uh attack on the capital was organized
through social media platforms
so certainly uh social media on january
6th
as for the domestic violent extremist
threat more broadly
uh has become a major factor a catalyst
if you will
uh the increased speed dissemination
efficiency accessibility that it
provides
it facilitates a greater interconnected
uh nature in a more decentralized way
and so we you know i sometimes say
terrorism today and we saw it on the
sixth
moves at the speed of social media um
and we try to work with social media
companies
uh to uh to get them to
more aggressively use the tools that
they have
to police their own platforms under
terms of service etc
and in particular to cooperate with us
so that we can bring
justice for those who hijack
these companies platforms to engage in
in some of the conduct we're talking
about
uh and that's where you've heard a
little bit about the encryption issue
come up that's a that's an important
part of this the we are moving in a
direction
we saw it on the sixth and we're seeing
it more and more
every day in this country where violent
extremists just like other bad actors
are taking advantage of encrypted
platforms to evade law enforcement
and the social media companies and the
technology companies are moving more and
more in a direction where if we don't
come up collectively with some kind of
solution
it's not going to matter how bulletproof
the legal process is or how horrific
horrific
the crime is or how heartbreaking the
victims are we will not be able to get
access to the content and the evidence
that we need to protect the american
people
and i think we will rule today
well director this area um raises a lot
of very complex questions of civil
liberties of
uh individual rights fundamental rights
to free expression
uh i am i'm also concerned about ways in
which uh online disinformation and
conspiracy theories lead to
radicalization and
help pave the way for this particularly
tragic event in the history of our
democracy and how
some of the ways in which social
platforms are structured social media
platforms are structured accelerate
um the spread of disinformation how
policy makers and platforms confront
these issues are going to be complex and
i look forward to
working with you to get the facts as the
fbi develops them
about what happened on january 6th two
last questions if i might
my colleague senator whitehouse asked
about responding to outstanding requests
for
information and i agree some of the
stonewalling that we saw
by a number of agencies over the
previous administration isn't acceptable
can you just reassure me the fbi will be
as responsive as possible
to information requests from this
committee absolutely it's my you know my
strong view is that you all have an
important
key function to perform in terms of your
oversight of the fbi
as with other agencies and it pains and
frustrates me
when we're not able to be as responsive
uh as you need us to be
and i commit to doing my best to see if
we can work with you
all to to get better on that front thank
you last um senator feinstein
asked you a series of questions about
the record number of nick's denials
last year um this is when someone goes
in tries to buy a gun
gets run through the background check
system and is denied
um they're a person prohibited often
because they're a convicted felon
um i'm soon going to be introducing a
bill with a colleague on this committee
um that would simply require that when
there is a
an attempt to buy that is denied because
someone is a person prohibited
that notification be given to state law
enforcement
that is the law in some states it is not
the law in the majority of states
does that seem to use something that
would be a good additional tool in the
toolkit
to allow state and local law enforcement
to act on the
tip that someone who is a person
prohibited has just lied and tried to
procure a weapon
certainly i think the the lied and tried
um information is often a valuable tool
uh
from an investigative perspective in
preventing more serious conduct
uh and we'd be happy to uh to meet with
you or engage with you to provide a
little bit better
sense of how all this works from an
operational perspective
um i know that uh the key consumer
of the information here as your question
eludes uh
our state local law enforcement so i
would want to make sure that we do it in
a way where we work with them as to what
they would find most useful
certainly as i said in response to
senator feinstein the volume
of nix checks overall and with it the
volume as a small subset of denials
has exploded over the course of the last
year
and so i i am mindful of the the
resource burden that it puts on
on everybody in the law enforcement
system but uh but be happy to talk with
you more about it
thanks i look forward to working with
you on that thank you mr chairman
senator says thank you chairman uh thank
you directory for being
here and thank you for the way you've
been available available to us on this
committee
and on the intel committee uh we've also
been grateful for your work and
availability
um we we've talked a good bit about the
intelligence failures around january 6th
but some of it is
how did we sort signal from noise and
some of it is the handoff
from the fbi and other entities to the
capitol police
as you do an after-action how much of
the problem
is the challenge of navigating a social
media world where
any drunk guy in a bar now has
amplification that he can be heard
around the world
and lots of it is just drunk guy in a
bar ranting and some of it is more
particular threats
because people can find communities of
kind of warped belief with other people
if they're planning something wicked
on social media how much of it is the
filtering through social media for you
to make sense of it and how much of the
january 6th failure was the handoff
from the fbi to capitol police well
senator as i said
when it comes to the handoff a lot of
the attention has really been about this
norfolk
sir which i think i've talked about it
at some length where we provided the
information to our partners in three
different ways
and as it was the information was raw
uncorroborated information
at the time certainly uh i think the
other part of your question
uh the filter the social media piece of
it
is a huge issue and it's something that
uh we and everybody in law enforcement
struggles with right now
um you know you use the drunk guy
example i guess
sometimes i refer to it used to be that
some angry
demented guy living in mom's basement
not that there's anything wrong with
that
you know in one part of the country is
now able to communicate with a similarly
angry guy
in grandma's attic in another part of
the country and they get each other spun
up now
and and how to to separate who's being
aspirational versus who's being
intentional
uh it won't shock you to learn uh and
hopefully not other members of the
committee
that the amount of angry hateful
unspeakable combative
violent even rhetoric on social media
exceeds what anybody in their worst
imagination is out there
and so trying to figure out who's just
saying you know what we ought to do is
x or everybody ought to do x
versus the person who's doing that and
actually getting traction
and then getting followers and of course
that's assuming they're not
communicating through encrypted channels
about all that stuff
is one of the hardest things there is to
do in today's world with the nature of
the violent extremism threat we face
social media companies play a huge role
in helping us with that
but you often hear us say if you see
something say something
to me the refinement here would be if
americans
see something on social media
that seems to have crossed that line
they need to say something
because that's going to be our best
source of information to prevent this
so it's helpful uh i've heard from
nebraska law enforcement before
at one level they don't really know what
to do with if you see something say
something
because it's not clear exactly where
they hand that information
so let's talk a little bit more about
the handoff between state and local law
enforcement as senator coons was
and the bureau but also between platform
technology platform con
content moderation and the bureau but
first just
inside the bureau give us comfort that
we're getting a lot better at this
because i don't think we're giving you
enough resources to get the right kind
of new human capital you're going to
need
but i'd love to be wrong so go from
three years ago to a year ago a year ago
to today in a day to a year from now
how are we getting better at filtering
signal from noise
and what kind of new human capital are
you hiring that should give us
confidence that we're going to get
better in this world that is
exploding with lots of online rant well
certainly we're
there's a number of things we're trying
to do to get better and i think we are
making progress but
all of it as you reference requires
resources
so there's a a data analytics piece
because the volume is so significant
that we need to
get better at being able to analyze the
data that we have
to do it in a timely way to separate the
wheat from the chaff
and that requires both tools analytical
tools
and we've had requests for those in the
budgets the last couple of years but
also people data analysts
who can devote their time to that who
have the experience
so that's part of it i think a second
part of it is
as i think i reference in response to an
earlier question
all these investigations that we do all
these arrests we make
are important not from not just from a
disruption perspective
but putting my intelligence hat on they
allow us to learn more about
where people communicate how they
communicate what the magic words are
all that kind of stuff so we get better
at better and anticipating from that
reason but
make no mistake we've got a long way to
go this is an incredibly hard problem
i know from communicating with my
foreign counterparts especially the five
eyes that they're struggling with it too
as to your point about people knowing
where to go
you know i will tell you that our tip
line our public access tip line
both the email tips and the phone tips
have exploded in volume
and we're doing things to kind of get
that information out to state local law
enforcement much more quickly
and certainly the social media companies
some of them have gotten better at
providing us more real-time information
when they see
something because they have a lot of
resources to devote to this problem
in terms of policing their own platform
so the more we can incentivize them to
do that that's a big part of this too
can i concretize the example so
i'm a high school teacher or a high
school principal and some kid comes to
me and says hey these kids
have always seemed to be online bullies
but now it seems like the things they're
saying
sound more violent what do you tell them
to do contact your local fbi field
office
so it is fbi it's not your local police
department well
i i think they could also contact state
local law enforcement
we all now work so closely together that
i think we view a call to one as a call
to us all we're all
we get the information we're you know
nine times out of ten going to be
pushing it to state local law
enforcement
as quickly as we can we do a lot of
outreach to the high schools
like you're talking about meeting with
teachers meeting with students meeting
with parents
to try to get them to understand better
what to be on the lookout for
what might be that indicator because the
one thing we know whether
it's whether it's any kind of domestic
violent extremism we've talked about
here this
this morning or frankly just the the
the horrific active shooter school
shooter situation
is that when you look back on the path
to the to the key moment almost every
single time there was a friend a family
member a neighbor
a classmate a co-worker something
somebody who knew the person well enough
to know
this is their baseline they've now
changed in a way that's scary to me
and no one knows better than the person
who knows them well and that's the
person we need to come forward when they
do and they're doing it more and more
we're able to get in front of it i'm i'm
basically at times so i won't ask a
question here but i'll flag one that i
want to continue talking with you about
i would love to hear your big national
pitch for these data analysts because
we need more great human capital serve
their country in this way
but i also want to be sure that our
training for these data
um for amendment sensibilities about
what they're there to do
they're looking for violence they're not
looking there to be
the national speech police so look
forward to continuing
that conversation thanks for your work
absolutely thanks senator sass senator
bloomfield
thank you mr chairman and thank you
director ray for being here today and
i want to join in expressing my
condolences for the loss of
those two agents and my thanks to the
thousands of
agents who work day in and day out to
make america
safer when you last appeared before this
committee in july of
2019 i expressed my concern that
donald trump's attacks against
members of congress and his other
rhetoric
quote might ignite white supremacists
and nationalist organizations
and encourage hate crimes end quote i
asked you whether you were concerned
about the increasing number and
intensity of his
attacks on public officials
and what the fbi was doing both
proactively and responsibly
about them and you said quote i think we
are very concerned
about any threats of violence against
any americans but certainly
that would prominently include our
elected
officials we've seen increasing attacks
by the president and others against
public officials
when the
rioters who came to the capitol
storm the citadel of democracy on
january 6
were inside they boasted proudly and
loudly that
they were doing what donald trump wanted
them to do
we have warned specifically about q anon
in a letter
uh dated december 8th 2020
a number of us members of the senate
warned that q anon specifically
was a threat
i would like to ask you whether
[Music]
the threat posed by q anon
and as you well know adherence of q anon
were
among the rioters very prominently
who stormed the capital whether the
continuing threat
is worsened when
prominent elected officials including
members of congress
endorse the q anon theory
uh well certainly we are concerned about
the q anon
phenomenon um which we view
as a um sort of loose sort of set of
conspiracy theories
uh and we've certainly seen domestic
violent extremists
uh of the sort that you're describing um
who uh cite that as part of their
motivation
uh so that's something that we we do but
but i apologize for interrupting
as you know my time is limited when
members of congress
as has happened endorse the q anon
theory
doesn't it worsen the threat of violence
well again our focus is on the violence
um
and on on the plans to commit violence
on the threats to commit violence it's
less on the rhetoric and the ideology
obviously the folks who engage in this
kind of violence
draw inspiration from a variety of
sources and we're concerned about any
source
that stimulates or motivates uh
violent extremism
well i'll i'll follow up in another
setting but uh
i am
frankly disappointed that you're not
discouraging one of the sources of
incitement which is prominent public
officials
endorsing a theory that in turn
resulted
in storming the united states capital
let me turn to hate crimes
uh hate crimes are underreported we're
seeing
a rising trend of hate crimes
particularly directed against asian
american pacific islanders
i have a bill called the no hate
act that would require more reporting
provide both incentives and requirements
wouldn't you think that kind of measure
is a good idea uh
so certainly uh we share your goal of
both
deterring uh and reducing hate crime but
also
particularly relevantly uh in promoting
better reporting more complete reporting
of hate crime and we are specifically
concerned
uh about hate crimes against asian
americans
uh as well i'm not
directly familiar with the bill but i i
think we
share the goal of trying to figure out
how to
improve reporting as you may know we
have you know neighbors which is a new
system that we're rolling out we're
trying to get to 100
uh on that and we'd be pleased to work
with you on figuring out how
how this bill might uh might
help advance that goal well then the no
hate
act would in fact lead to better
reporting if
87 percent of hate crimes are unreported
now
that is a searing indictment of the
present system we need to know more and
particularly about
asian americans and island pacific as
being victims
of them i know you don't want to be a
as you said armchair quarterback
but uh you're going to be
armchaired quarterback by the american
people
and i think the american people
listening to these past 10 days of
hearing
and knowing how much information there
was
out there on social media in other
forms about these thugs
and rioters coming to washington
organized groups three percent of
proud boys and others
are wondering why didn't the fbi
sound the alarm i know there was
a communication through that threat
assessment i know you've talked about
the agencies that were
hearing that assessment but here we have
the united states capital where
a key function of democracy enabling the
peaceful transition of power was taking
place
and a threat of violence and even death
to them
why didn't you go to the gang of eight
why didn't you
sound the alarm in some more visible
and ringing way well senator
i guess a couple things one uh over the
course of 2020 we repeatedly
repeatedly put out intelligence products
on this very issue domestic violent
extremism domestic violence extremism
specifically tied to the election
domestic violent extremism specifically
tied the election and continuing beyond
the election
up through the inauguration and
specifically in december of 2020.
in addition to that in connection with
the the one piece of
raw intelligence that's been discussed
so much here today
we did pass that on to the people in the
best position to take action
on the threat uh not one not two but
three different ways now
more broadly in terms of what's out in
social media
uh as a number of the questions here
today have elicited
i think it highlights and your question
highlights one of the most challenging
jobs for law enforcement in today's
world with social media there is so much
chatter often unattributed to somebody
in a neatly identifiable way where
people are saying
unbelievably horrific angry combative
things
using language about beheading and
shooting and explosives and all kinds of
things like that
and separating out which ones are
getting traction which ones reflect
intention as opposed to aspiration is
something that we spend an enormous
amount of time
trying to do sometimes we don't have the
luxury of time in the ability to make
those judgments
i can assure you that as i said i think
to senator klobuchar
uh my standard is we're trying to bat a
thousand we want to thwart every attack
and anytime there's an attack that's not
thwarted we and our partners want to
make sure
that we figure out how to do even better
preventing that we're pleased that the
inauguration
for example went smoothly
notwithstanding threats and chatter that
we were seeing
not just here in the national capital
region but against state capitals all
across the country
and our focus was on engaging with uh
with all of our partners our state local
partners i did a conference call with
like a thousand
plus police chiefs from around the
country about the state capitals
that's the kind of thing we were doing
to try to make sure that we're doing
the grind the hard work to get in front
of the threat
and we're going to keep working at it
every single day i
i understand your response
what i don't understand is why
this chatter raw intelligence
didn't prompt a stronger warning
an alarm going to the very top
of the united states congress because
clearly the united states congress
was under severe threat thank you
senator thank you mr chairman
senator hawley thank you mr chairman
director ray thanks for being here
can i just go back to a series of
questions that senator lee asked you he
asked you about the geolocation
and metadata aspects and gathering
uh related to gathering of metadata that
is related to
your investigation of the january 6 riot
you said you weren't
familiar with the specifics can i just
clarify
your responses to him so when you say
you're not familiar
are you saying that you don't know
whether or not the bureau has scooped up
geolocation data metadata from cell
phone
records from cell phone towers or do you
not know are you saying that the bureau
maybe or maybe hasn't done it just tell
me the
tell me what you know about this so when
it comes to geolocation data
specifically
again not in a specific instance but
just even the use of geolocation data
i would not be surprised to learn but i
do not know for a fact
that we were using geolocation data
under any situation with connection with
the investigation of the sixth
but again we do use geolocation data
under specific
authorities and specific instances
because this is such a sprawling
investigation
that would not surprise me when it comes
to metadata
which is a little bit different
obviously than geolocation data
i feel confident that we are using
various legal authorities to look at
metadata
under a variety of situations um but
again the specifics of
when under what circumstances with whom
that kind of thing i'm not in a position
to testify about with the sprawl and
size of the investigation and certainly
not
uh in a you know congressional hearing
what authorities do you have in mind
you said that you're using the relevant
authorities what what authorities
are they well we have various forms of
legal process we can serve
on companies that will allow us to get
active and that's been done
well we're using a lot of legal process
in connection with the investigation so
yes
but specifically serving serving process
on companies
using invoking your various legal powers
to get that
data from companies that's been that's
been done in the case of gathering this
data
and gathering metadata
again i don't know the specifics but i
feel confident that that has happened
because metadata is also
often something that we look at and we
have a variety of legal tools that allow
us to do that under certain
circumstances
what about the cell tower data that uh
was reportedly scooped up by the bureau
on the day
during in fact while the riot was
underway what what's happened
what's happened to that data do you
still have it has it been retained
do you have plans to retain it again
whatever we're doing with cell phone
data i'm confident that we're doing it
you know in conjunction with
our appropriate legal tools and working
well
here's what i'm trying to get at i think
it's what senator lee was trying to get
how are we going to know
what you are doing with it and how are
we going to evaluate
the bureau's conduct if we if we don't
know
what authorities you're invoking what
precisely you're doing what you're
retaining
i mean this is you you said to him
repeatedly you weren't familiar with the
specifics you've now said it to me
i i don't know i'm not sure how this
committee is supposed to evaluate
anything that the bureau
is doing you're basically saying just
trust us i mean how are we how are we
going to know do we have to wait till
the end of your investigation to find
out what you've done
well uh certainly i have to be careful
about discussing an ongoing
investigation which i'm sure you can
appreciate
uh but but all the tools that we have
are done in conjunction with prosecutors
and lawyers from the justice department
now
if there's information we can provide
you before an investigation is completed
that goes through what some of the
the authorities we have the tools we
have etc we could probably provide some
information like that that might be
useful to you
uh to help answer the question that
would be helpful uh thank you i'll hold
you to that let me let me ask you about
some other things that have been
reported
um in the press particularly there have
been a series of reports
that the bureau has worked with banks in
the course of the investigation
into the january 6 riot and and the both
before and after
and that some banks particular bank of
america may have handed over data for
200 plus clients who may have used their
credit or debit cards to make purchases
in the dc area
what do you know about this has bank of
america voluntarily turned over
information to the bureau
about its customers i don't know any of
the specifics so i'd have to look into
that
and so it has the fbi requested similar
information
from any other companies to your
knowledge again i'd sitting here right
now i do not know the answer to that
question i do know that we work
with private sector partners including
financial institutions in a variety of
ways
all the time in a variety of
investigations but exactly the specifics
of
what may or may not have happened here
that i don't know sitting here as we're
talking today as i'm sure you can
appreciate my concern here is that
12 usc 3403s prohibits financial
institutions from turning over
confidential client records
unless of course they've got reasonable
suspicion that there's a crime being
committed
now the news reports on this have
indicated that the financial
institutions were doing this in
cooperation with the bureau without any
such
indication of a crime they're just
turning over reams of consumer data that
obviously would be a major
legal problem a major legal concern can
you try and
give me some answers to these questions
i appreciate you saying you don't know
today you're not aware of what's going
on but can you look into this and follow
up with me on this i'd be happy to see
if there's more information we can
provide you on the subject as i said we
have a variety of ways in which we
engage with financial institutions in
particular
and as you reference there's a number of
legal authorities that describe
when you can and cannot do that and how
that's supposed to work
so i don't want to get out as they say
over my skis and try to characterize
what may have happened in this specific
specific instance
but i'm happy to look into it and see if
there's more information we can provide
what about some of the technology
companies facebook google twitter apple
amazon has the
has the fbi had contacts with those tech
platforms
following the events of the sixth uh
we've certainly had contact with a
number of the social media companies
uh in connection with the sixth um so
that much i know
have has the bureau sought to compel any
of those companies to turn over user
data
related to the sixth well again i don't
i can't tell you the specifics here but
what i will tell you
is that uh we i
feel certain that we have served legal
process on those companies
uh which we do with some frequency uh
and we have received information from
some of those companies and whether
that's true of every single one of the
companies you listed i can't say for
sure but i
i suspect it is because we work with the
social media companies quite a lot
are you aware of any of the companies
voluntarily turning over data to the
bureau
in relationship to the events of the
sixth uh i can't sitting here right now
i can't say for sure
just one more question mr chairman
time's almost expired
is the fbi are you are you currently
pressuring any of these
platforms these social media platforms
or tech platforms to include back doors
and their software that would help
defeat end-to-end encryption
are we pressuring are you encouraging or
are you are you pushing for
are you uh is there a desire to get
such access we are not trying to get
back doors uh that is i think
a criticism that gets leveled our way by
people who
don't understand our position often so i
appreciate the opportunity
uh to address it here uh we are
concerned
about end and encryption especially
default and encryption
uh in connection with a lot of these
platforms and we are concerned
uh that if these companies continue to
move in the trajectory that they're
moving in we are going to find ourselves
in a situation where no matter how
bulletproof or ironclad the legal
authority no matter how compelling the
facts and circumstances
no matter how horrific the crime or
heartbreaking the victim
we will not be able to get access to the
content that we need to keep people safe
what we have been suggesting uh and the
cryptologers and cryptographers that i
talked to
say this is doable is for the companies
themselves
to build in a way to have legal access
when confronted with a proper legal
authority so that they can get access to
information and provide it in response
to a warrant or a court order
we're not going to have a key we're not
asking for a back door that's a myth
an urban legend that has been directed
our way
but this is a subject that i think the
american people need to understand
because decisions
that affect the life and blood of
americans all over this country
which normally are made by our elected
representatives are in effect getting
made
in corporate offices in big technology
companies and
different people can come down in
different places on that balancing but i
would submit that's a balancing that
should be made
up here and not by one company based on
its business model
and in the context for example of child
exploitation
we get and to facebook's great credit we
get
millions millions of tips on child
exploitation
through nick mc every year that help us
prevent and rescue kids
hundreds of kids every year if they move
forward in the direction they're moving
in which is the direction by the way
that apple
already went we're going to be a
position where those tips those leads
that content that information
will drop into the abyss
so the tips will be gone the victims all
those kids will still be out there
the pedophiles that are exploiting them
they'll still be out there the only
thing that'll be different
is that neither the company nor we in
law enforcement will know
who they are where they are or what
they're doing and i don't think that's a
situation
that we want to find ourselves in so we
would welcome the opportunity to work
with the companies
perhaps uh encouraged or incentivized
through congress to get to a situation
where we can balance
strong cyber security absolutely it's a
key part of our mission as well at the
fbi
along with strong flesh and blood
security especially
for america's children thank you senator
senator hirono is on remote can you hear
me senator
yes thank you mr chairman
dr wade excuse me dr ray following the
january 6 insurrection you
and other senior law enforcement
officials
were missing from public view and the
people who were providing the briefings
to the public
were the the d.c acting u.s attorney and
the assistant director of the fbi's
washington field office i hope you agree
that at a time like this
it would be very important for
high-level law enforcement
people like you and others to have brief
the public to limit the
spread of misinformation about what
happened and who
was behind what happened wouldn't you
agree
certainly i agree it's important to
prevent misinformation
as much as we can consistent with our
legal responsibilities
and part of the misinformation that
happened
was that and you've testified that so
far there is no evidence of
fake trump supporters committing or
provoking violence during the january
6th wyatt
the capital that's part of the
misinformation that got out
were you aware of these false
claims
uh well certainly along the way we've
seen a whole variety of claims from a
variety of people
about the investigation into the january
6th
attack just like with a lot of other
high profile attacks
whether i can recall exactly when the
first time i've heard that specific
claim
uh i don't know for sure this is this is
part of the kind of um
false information and narrative that
that got out blaming
others such as antifa for what happened
so that that is why i think it is really
important for
you and others like you to be out front
you've been asked some questions about
hate crimes and you acknowledge that
there is a rise
in hate crimes against the aapi asian
american pacific islander community
wouldn't you agree that calling the coba
19
the kung flu or the china virus
adds to the kind of of targeted hate
crimes that we are seeing arise
uh against the aapi community
well i don't know that it's really my
place as fbi director to start
uh weighing in on rhetoric but i can
assure you that that's not a language i
would ever
use and hate crimes against asian
americans and pacific islanders
is something that we are concerned about
we take very seriously
we are investigating where we have facts
sufficient to do that we're also engaged
in a variety of
forms of outreach to the public
i think we've done you know 60 plus
training or liaison events with the
asian american
pacific islander community since just
march of last year
we've put out intelligence reports to
our partners
about hate crimes against that community
in particular
and it's something we take very
seriously i commend you for
working with i assume local and state uh
state and local law enforcement entities
as well as community advocacy groups
to uh to deal with the rise in hate
crimes against asian americans and in
fact
just a few weeks ago there were
lethal attacks on
there seems to be a targeting of senior
asians and so lethal attacks in san
francisco
and in new york and i think these are
totally unprovoked
attacks and so
i i think that we need to continue to
focus on what the community can do and
what law enforcement
enforcement can do to make sure that
these crimes are
prosecuted as the hate crimes that they
are and i think it is also important for
for leaders to not
uh fan the flames by calling covet 19
the china virus or kung flu
you also testified and you asked some
questions about the role of social media
by these extremist groups
and you said that terrorism moves at the
speed of social
media senators warner klobuchar and i
recently introduced the safe tech
act which would pull back section 230
immunity
from tech companies for things like
civil rights violations and wrongful
death suits
do you think that exposing these
companies to civil liability
would force them basically to
take extremist content off
of their platforms or to take these
kinds of content more seriously and do
something about them
well senator uh i want to be careful not
to
get out ahead of the rest of the
administration
and weighing in on specific pieces of
legislation but having said that
uh i think there are a few things i
could say you know one is
while the immunity uh under section 230
has
obviously helped the evolution of the
social media industry it's also allowed
it
to avoid a lot of the burdens and risks
that other
brick and mortar companies have had to
face and it means that important
decisions
uh that affect many aspects of society
that would normally be made by the
people's
elected representatives are now being
made in corporate offices
in the industry and so while i can't
comment on specific legislation i
certainly can tell you that i see the
value
maybe it's the best way of putting it uh
of incentivizing
online platforms to address
both illicit content uh
on their platforms uh and to assist law
enforcement in bringing to justice
criminals who use those platforms to
victimize americans
and then there is also the concern that
as
entities such as facebook and twitter do
more to
control uh modify these this kind of
content then i know this could encourage
um drive the extremists to use encrypted
platforms like
telegram and signal so that's another
area that we're going to need to
address i wanted to turn briefly to
your testimony that that identifies lone
wolf actors as a concern
for you and i think that with regard to
loma factors we need a
probably a a whole of society approach
so what can we all do to deal with the
problem of
lone wolf extremists so i appreciate the
question
uh we do consider that the the lone
actor
uh i've i've sort of stopped using the
term wolf because i feel like it gives
them too much credit
um but the lone actors whether they're
homebound extremists or domestic violent
extremists
uh is a is a real threat because one of
the
a because it's so uh pervasive but b
because unlike somebody who's working as
part of a large group
somebody acting alone has fewer people
they're in contact with which means
fewer dots to connect
et cetera it makes it that much harder
for us to get in front of
what we desperately need is
more and more situations where the
members of the public who know that
person
who see the transformation who see
things starting to change in a way that
they know is different and has
become much darker and more dangerous
those people to speak up to
contact law enforcement whoever they
trust in law enforcement
uh to to alert people to the threat and
the good news if there's any good news
in this is that we are seeing that
happen more and more
uh in this country uh i you know we've
had lots of people
uh as heartbreaking as it must be turn
in family members when they see this
transformation
because they know that having us or our
partners intercede
may not only prevent that person from
committing an attack against an innocent
american but also may in some instances
result in that person being off-ramp to
get
help as opposed to potentially being
killed by law enforcement or
incarcerated or something else
so we need the people we always say if
you see
something say something and most people
picture the abandoned backpack in a
greyhound bus terminal
obviously we want people to see
something and say something there but we
also need
people if they see something about
somebody
to say something uh and the more of that
we can have and the more
members of congress as as key voices in
their communities in their
in your home states can encourage people
to do that
that's one of the key weapons we have as
a country uh to your to use your phrase
a whole of society
uh defense against this threat thank you
thank you mr chairman
uh senator cotton director ray welcome
uh first i wanted to i was deeply
saddened by the loss of special agent
stan alfin and lauren schwarzenberger
and i want to extend condolences to
their families and to the
agents who worked with them the entire
bureau my wife and i know
many of your agents across the country
and are extremely grateful for the work
they do to keep our community safe
i want to turn to some of your written
testimony uh you say
that the fba fbi assesses homegrown or
homegrown violent extremists as the
greatest most immediate international
threat to the homeland
these extremists are us-based
individuals located in and radicalized
primarily in the u.s who are not
receiving individualized
direction from global jihad inspired
foreign terrorist organizations
but are inspired largely by isis and al
qaeda to commit violence
so what you're saying there director ray
if i understand it correctly is that
dangerous though the threat is from
other kinds of extremists like racial
supremacist groups or anarchist groups
the most dangerous threat we have in the
country from extremism remains
jihadist is that correct well the i
think the key word
there was international uh i don't have
the written
statement for the record in front of me
but what i would say is
we view the maybe step back what we view
as the most dangerous threat
to americans today is
largely lone actors some cases small
cells if you will largely radicalize
online
already here in the united states
attacking soft targets
using crude readily accessible weapons
motivated either by
jihadist inspirations or by a variety of
domestic inspiration so we have the
hves the homegrown vile extremists which
are the jihadist inspired
and we have the dves the domestic
violent extremists
who are inspired by domestic sources
that bucket
which have a lot in common with each
other is the greatest threat
uh the greatest terrorism threat we face
as a country okay
i want to turn to another kind of
potential terrorist threats uh we talked
a lot here about domestic terrorism
obviously international terrorism
remains a serious threat an important
part
of the federal government's
counterterrorism work remains trying to
prevent
foreign terrorists from reaching our
shores is that correct yes
and part of the screening process is
checking our own criminal criminal
record and terrorism databases
but it does rely heavily on foreign
governments both providing us with data
about criminal terrorist ties
and also to document security practices
so terrorists can't obtain fake ids is
that correct
uh certainly that's an important part of
kind of hardening our
our you know homeland defense if you
will and your predecessor testified to
congress in 2015
that without cooperation from those
governments if the terror if a terrorist
is not already in
our own databases we could quote query
our database until the cows come home
but there will be nothing to show up end
quote unless foreign governments work
with us is that still the case
certainly we depend heavily on
cooperation from foreign governments to
to make that
that kind of defense effective let's
turn to a few of those foreign
governments
is it still the case that syria and iran
are both nations that share little if
any information
with the united states about potential
travelers or immigrants coming to our
country
i will confess that i i'm not sure i
know the answer sitting here today but
i would be flabbergasted if the answer
were anything other than yes it's still
the case
um still the case that syria and iran
i'm sorry that
that uh libya and syria um are both
countries that lack effective control
over significant parts of their
territory and therefore cannot provide
information from people coming from
those parts of their country
i believe that to be the case um what
about
myanmar also known as burma where there
was a military coup last week
uh is it true that the united states now
faces serious obstacles to vet
individuals coming from burma i'm not
sure i know the answer on burma but i
suspect the answer is the same
and finally in this rose gallery what
about north korea is it true that north
korea remains uncooperative and
providing us information about north
korean nationals that might try to come
to the united states
i have rarely heard north korea come up
in the context of
cooperativeness thank you um i just want
to note before we close on this topic
that all of those nations syria iran
libya burma and north korea
were among the nations from which
president biden lifted travel
restrictions by executive order on his
very first day in office without any
plan in place
to improve security for those travel
situations each of them represents a
real threat to the united states
i want to turn to another kind of threat
we face which is crime and gang violence
in particular
unfortunately both drug trafficking and
violent crime are now on the rise in the
united states are street gangs
driving a significant part of violent
crime on streets across america
well certainly when i go around and i've
talked with state and local law
enforcement
in all 50 states uh i think the number
one issue you would hear about from
from maybe all of them is violent crime
and what it drives it in each city state
is
town is different but uh it's not just
the national gangs
you know the ms-13s the 18th street uh
gangs etc
a lot of times it's the neighborhood
gangs that are really top of mind when
you talk to chiefs and sheriffs around
this country
yeah and those gangs of whatever type
they often use violent crime as a way to
expand their territory and exert more
control so then they can use
seek money-making enterprises like drug
trafficking or prostitution property
crimes like robbery
is that yes yes so let's talk about
ms-13 since you raised it
um ms-13 has gained notoriety for some
particularly brutal climbs across the
country in recent years
and they continue to expand their
influence in the united states is that
right
well i know we've made significant
strides against ms-13 over the last
uh you know 18 months or so um but it is
a it is a very significant
uh gang threat uh and the brutality the
savagery
uh and the level of uh kind of
organization that exists there
is uh is something that has to be taken
extremely seriously
and it remains primarily a central
american and especially in el salvador
and gang is that correct
well certainly from that from the
triangle the so-called triangle
uh but yes el salvador is one place from
which a lot of people
come they don't exactly have not
membership cards i'm sure have a
membership direct
uh directory um unless they're named by
another gang member
do you still use methods like gang
tattoos to identify who belongs to ms-13
that would be one piece of information
would be relevant we're obviously
talking to
human sources witnesses informants um
collecting information from from
partners etc
and then uh i know that your safe
streets task forces and your national
gang intelligence center and other units
often work together with the department
of homeland security
and with state and local law enforcement
to find and to prosecute and deport
these gang members
and your professional opinion today is
immigration and customs enforcement
supporting too many or too few ms-13
gang members
well i don't know that i've tracked the
deportation uh rate uh related to ms-13
members when we come across ms-13
members in this country our focus has
been on
on locking them up and putting them in
federal prison uh as much as we can
uh which is where we'd like to have them
um
[Music]
in addition to the units that you listed
off i think correctly
i would also cite uh our tag our
transnational
group which is a task force that we have
in el salvador because we actually have
pretty effective uh results with uh
u.s law enforcement working with el
salvador law enforcement
and to a somewhat lesser extent the
other two countries in the triangle
uh to take down some of the ms-13
members
in their home country as well so it's
the two pieces together
so i can't say sitting here right now
anything about the immigration
posture but certainly when we find
ms-13 gang members here we want to put
them in orange jumpsuits where they get
to spend
a lot of time in our prisons thank you
well when it comes to ms-13 it won't
surprise you to know that i support the
lock em up policy but also support the
deported policy
thank you senator cotton uh director ray
hello i know it's been a long day and i
appreciate you you're on the very tail
end
of uh the uh the questioner so i
appreciate your
i first just want to associate myself
with uh
maybe not the heat uh that you received
from senator whitehouse but definitely
the spirit of what he was talking about
and i appreciate your commitment uh to
meet his concerns which are concerns
i've heard on both sides of the aisle
it's very hard to play our role our
constitutionally mandated role if we
don't have the information to do the
oversight of your agency
so i do appreciate your commitments um i
also want to join
what is i think you've seen a really
bipartisan
condolences for the loss of daniel alph
and alvin and lauren schwarzenberger
that is the greatest sacrifice anyone
can make for this nation which is to die
in the line of duty
in protecting others i'm aware that
there are other officers that were
injured
other agents that were injured i hope
they're recovering well
they are they are i had the opportunity
the the morning after the shooting to uh
to go down not just to meet with
laura and dan's families but also to
visit
the hospital uh and happily i think the
the four
injured agents um should make a full
recovery
well would you please express from the
entire committee um not only our
condolences to the families but our
robust concern
uh for their recovery and their
well-being and should they need anything
you obviously have uh allies here
uh in their well-being thank you senator
um i
i you and i have had a uh one of my a
treasured conversation frankly to have
the
you showed me the honor of coming to
visit me before you were
sat with me in my office before you you
you stepped into that job and i really
appreciated
our conversation about the challenges we
still have in this
country around racial issues and um
the urgency for the fbi which has abused
its power before
whether it's investigations of martin
luther king or other ways to really
set an example for the largest uh driver
in many ways
as we pledge allegiance to this flag
this driver towards being a just
nation um i i just want to ask you
though about your team
we know that diverse teams are better
uh everybody from harvard business
school to every top con
business consulting agency has shown
study after study that diverse teams are
stronger teams but especially ones
in law enforcement that have such a
mandate that you have uh
having diversity is really important and
so i guess my first question is is
how diverse is the fbi's workforce now
uh
in terms of gender religious and racial
diversity
um so senator this is a topic
that as you may recall from our our
prior visit
uh is very important to me personally
and something i've tried to make as a
priority
uh we're addressing it in a variety of
ways uh but in terms of results
uh there is i guess i would characterize
it as
cautiously optimistic so uh
on the racial diversity front uh our
special agent class
uh has been more diverse with each
year over the past few years in each
case
more certainly than the diversity
percentage of the workforce that exists
uh and this year uh which i think is a
bright spot
the percentage the racial diversity of
our applicant pool is much higher
than it was in years past on gender
uh much the same applications the
diversity of applications is up
significantly the diversity
uh gender diversity of our chronicle
classes is up
uh we've set i've set aggressive uh
targets for our field offices and those
targets are for the most part being
exceeded
uh so we're doing a number of things to
try to address the issue we have what we
call diversity agent recruitment events
which were easier to do pre-covered but
that you know that a lot of times i
would go to in different parts of the
country myself and speak at
uh we have a very encouraging
project we've started with 300
entertainment that's focused on
um historically black colleges and
universities and trying to improve our
recruiting pipeline there
um can i maybe just ask you could you
share that data with the committee
uh of the progress that you're making
sure i think i think there's definitely
information we could provide uh
separately and then your leadership team
can you provide the diversity
of the of the leadership team that you
have around you sure well i will say
uh yes is the answer but i will say that
on that front um i've recently
uh appointed to you know we have i'm not
sure how much you may remember about our
structure
uh but we have at the very top of the
fbi
six eads executive assistant directors
each one of us over a branch that has
multiple divisions
uh so just over the last couple of
months uh
as people retire uh i've replaced one of
the
uh eads with an asian-american woman who
oversees our human resources branch
and one of the other of these six eads
with an african-american male
who oversees our intelligence branch
which includes not just our entire
intelligence function but our our
private sector engagement
and our law enforcement partner
engagement as well
um i also uh appointed i want to
honor the time here i look forward i
know you'll be available to discuss that
more and get the information
um uh in the in the minute or so i have
left
um i've really i think a lot of the
questioning has been uh
very uh uh illustrative of a lot of the
challenges we face i appreciate that
from members of both sides of the
uh of the of the deus here i i just
wanted to drill into
something we've talked about the uh
extremist groups that were
at the capitol we talked about many
others but as i've seen interviews with
folks there were many people that were
just saying i'm here because
president trump now former president
trump wanted us here
and it seemed that this lie that was
told over and over again
that many people felt like that their
government had betrayed them
that the courts and after court case
after court case that
uh uh republican official republican
official were all just dead wrong
really believed in the lie and felt like
they were left with no choice but to try
to stop
the peaceful transfer of power and so i
guess i just asked
to begin with is that attorney general
barr
said that he had quote not seen fraud
on a scale that could have affected a
different
outcome in the election do you agree
with attorney general barr's statement
that there is
absolutely no evidence of voter fraud
that could have
changed the outcome of the 2020
presidential election
i agree with attorney general barr and
and to be crystal clear on this as fbi
director
who is these would be federal crimes
you're aware of no evidence of
widespread voter fraud in the 2020
presidential election correct
uh we are not aware of any widespread
evidence of voter fraud much less that
would have affected the
outcome in the presidential election all
right
well i have great respect uh for senator
kennedy and i see him as a friend i'm
not going to abuse the incredible power
that dick durbin has given me right now
although power is going through my head
but i'm going to police myself
and defer to the good senator kennedy
thank you uh mr chairman i didn't hear
you did you call me
i called you mr chairman thank you sir
thank you sir
that sounds very good thank you again mr
chairman
uh mr director
i've listened uh from my office to your
testimony today
tell me who had the authority to call
out the national guard
on january 6
my understanding well my understanding
is that the
decisions to call out the national guard
in one sense are the responsibility of
the secretary of defense
uh but in another sense director i'm
sorry
to interrupt you um but
i think we can agree that the fbi had
credible information
that there was likely to be violence
from january 6.
can we agree on that well i don't know
that we
had assessed its credibility we
certainly had information that was
concerning uh about the potential for
violence
uh in connection with the january 6
events and as we discussed here this
morning right
one piece of information that was most
specific uh
that i'm aware of was past uh you know
quite well
based on that information and i'm sorry
to interrupt but
we just keep nibbling at the edges and
dancing around the issue
and i understand i'm not asking to throw
anybody under the bus
chris i i get it but we need to find out
what happened
now if if if you were king for a day
based on the information that you had
maybe not at the time but later on
would you have called out the fbi i mean
the uh
the national guard
you know senator as you said i really
want to be careful not to be armchair
quarterbacking
others i think the national guard we
have seen
can play a very important role
well i sure you know i'm not trying to
be rude but my time's limited
um well who made the call not to
based on your information who made the
call not to call out the fbi whether
they should ever shouldn't
not call the fbi i'm sorry i'm tired
the national guard um
well i would defer to others who were
more involved in that discussion but
from what i have heard
what i have read my understanding is
that at one stage of the process
the local government was of the view
that it did not need
the national guard's assistance who do
you mean by the local government
the mayor yes um
so the mayor didn't call out the
national guard at the
at the beginning uh what do you mean by
the beginning well you know in the day
or two leading up
to the sixth and then as to exactly how
it played out on the sixth itself
i mean clearly our people uh were
overrun
but by by the nut jobs so
we're making progress here okay so the
mayor
or the city government decided not to
call out the fbi
of the uh national guard at that time um
what about the the house
sergeant-at-arms
uh i don't know what role the house
agile arms played with respect to
the national guard okay how about the
senate sergeant
same answer okay how about the
capitol police the chief of capitol
police did the chief capitol police make
the call not to call out the national
guard
i don't know the answer to that my
understanding is that the
law enforcement officials here with
responsibility over the capital
uh that they were varying just for
different views about whether or not the
national guard was appropriate and when
at what level but all i really know on
that is what i've
same thing you've seen you know in the
press coverage of
of the event okay that's enough on that
um
i listen to your comments about
diversity and i thank you
for your for your good work there i
think any fair-minded person has to
conclude that uh
the diversity is a strength not a
weakness but this subject comes up a lot
and i think it's going to come up a lot
again and
and that's not a criticism that's just a
an observation
do you believe that the fbi is a
systemically
racist institution
no i now having said that i do believe
the fbi needs to be more diverse
and more inclusive than it is and that
we need to work a lot harder at that and
we're trying to work a lot harder on
that
do you believe that the fbi is a
systemic
uh systemically
sexist or misogynistic institution
again that's not the way i would
describe the fbi that i know and see
every day but again it's a place where
we need to be more
diverse and inclusive and we need to
work harder at that
and we are working harder than we've got
progress that we still need to make to
at least to be
satisfactory by my stand okay fair
enough
um mr director have you ever been to
hong kong
no wonderful place wonderful people
um the chinese communist party is
destroying it
if congress passed a bill and
and said to the good people of uh
of hong kong who yearn for freedom
come to america we're going to follow
our friends in britain
say come here you want to get off out
from under the thumb
of the communist party come to america
we welcome you
do you think the fbi and law enforcement
has
the ability to to screen for
spies one of the criticisms of the
proposition i just
stated is well we would be letting in
spies
do you think based on your knowledge of
security that we could
catch most of the spies
well uh i yield to no one in my faith
and confidence in the great work of the
men and women of the fbi but i will tell
you that the um
the chinese counterintelligence threat
is the greatest threat
certainly the greatest
counterintelligence threat that we face
as a country
and the this the sheer number of what we
would refer to as non-traditional
collectors
um working on behalf of the chinese
countries party is something that is a
massive resource challenge for the fbi
that was probably an unfair question i'm
not asking you to guarantee
anything and the few seconds i have left
and begging
the indulgence of our esteemed chairman
who's doing a much better job than
durban by the way oh he's back
um
the horowitz report can you tell me how
many people you have referred for
prosecution at the fbi as a result of
the harwich report
for prosecution or for discipline for
prosecution first just give me numbers
because i don't want to
abuse my time well i i you know the the
prosecution
issue related to anything to do with the
horace report
inspect specter i get it how many of you
fired so
all the people all the car most of the
people involved in horus report are
former employees
of the ones who are current every single
one of them
even if mentioned only in passing has
been referred to our office of
professional responsibility which is our
disciplinary arm now that
piece and this is important that piece
of it
because we're cooperating fully with mr
durham's investigation
at his request we had slowed that
process down to allow his
criminal investigation to proceed so
at the moment uh that process is uh
still underway in order to make sure
that we're being appropriately sensitive
to the criminal investigation
okay so you've had to hold up as a
result of the criminal miss
i'm sorry i went over mr chairman and
you're
i'm sure glad you hear booker was just
screwing everything up
senator padilla and i'm sure you'll do a
better job than the previous questioner
thank you seven i will do my best uh
uh mr director ray uh other members of
the committee have raised
uh their concerns over the increase in
hate crimes
in recent years against latinos
african-americans the
lgbtqia community and others
over the last year we've seen a
significant increase in violence
specifically against asian americans
including in my home state of california
no earlier in this hearing members
raised the recent
lethal attacks in san francisco and new
york
as some examples just last week in
sacramento california a man returned to
the premises of an asian
family-run butcher shop with a mutilated
cat carcass for no apparent reason
other than to stoke fear the incident
is currently under investigation as a
hate crime
it's clear to me that this uptick in
violence against
asian americans is the direct result of
racist
rhetoric used by political leaders with
intentional regard
to the coronavirus pandemic such as when
former president donald trump has used
offensive references
to the coronavirus indeed a march 2020
fbi assessment conducted by the fbi's
houston office and distributed to law
enforcement across the country and i'll
quote
it well it predicted a future surge in
hate crimes against asian americans due
to the spread of coronal virus and i
want to quote from that assessment
the fbi makes this assessment based on
the assumption
that a portion of the u.s public will
associate covet 19
with china and asian american
populations
so i know senator hirono has already
raised the topic but i wanted to
ask a couple more specific follow-up
questions uh to what extent
directorate do you believe the increase
in violence against asian americans has
been influenced by
reckless rhetoric concerning the
pandemic
to what steps is the fbi taking to
address the increase
in hate crimes against asian americans
and three part of that
i hope is uh an update on how the fbi is
proactively working to overcome
trust issues in immigrant communities
and communities of color
so senator uh let me try to take all
three questions in turn
um first uh i want to be careful
as fbi director not to start to get in
the business of
of kind of weighing in and
characterizing rhetoric
because as you know you know we focus on
the violence
not on the ideology or the motivation so
i i would largely on that issue
uh just reaffirm the intelligence
assessment that's already been produced
through the appropriate channels on the
second
two questions uh in terms of
trying to be proactive
a number of things that we're doing so
in addition to our investigations
which we which we work closely with
state local
uh in some cases tribal and other
federal law enforcement agencies
uh and that we have some cases we'll be
able to bring federal
cases working with our civil rights
division counterparts the prosecutors
in other cases even if it's going to be
a state or local charge which sometimes
may be the best charge available based
on the facts
we are trying to provide forensic
support other kinds of expertise and
experience to help support the state
local prosecution
we're also trying to do a lot more
public outreach
which is both with the community itself
but also with state local law
enforcement in some cases
uh field offices are bringing them
together so it's a group discussion
which i think has a lot of value we're
also providing training so we're doing a
lot of training
we've done hundreds of seminars
workshops
for both law enforcement and community
groups
religious organizations so forth and
that includes hate crimes training
not just for the hundreds of special
agents at the fbi but for thousands
thousands of police officers uh when it
comes specifically to the last part of
your question
the um the trust issues
uh you know part of that is is
demonstrating through our work
that we're going to do the right thing
in the right way uh and that we're going
to respond
just as aggressively and professionally
to crimes against them as victims
as they see with other kinds of crimes
and we have done
just since march of uh of 2020
i think we've done 60 over 60
liaison events uh or trainings
specifically geared towards the asian
american pacific islander community
and we've also tried to put out
intelligence reports like the one you
referenced that
call out the issue great but i think it
just uh yet another example of the value
of increased
improved diversity not just throughout
the ranks of the agency
but especially amongst agents and
amongst leadership
now your examples of collaboration with
local law enforcement actually a great
transition to my next question
some of the most striking revelations in
the aftermath of the january 6th
insurrection here in the capitol were
reports
reports that some members of the capitol
police were sympathetic
to the insurrectionists that they posed
for photos provided directions
and may have even expressed support for
those attacking the very building
they're sworn to protect
i understand that six capitol police
officers have been suspended
and at least 29 others are under
investigation for their alleged role
in the attack we've also learned that
among those participating
in the interaction were numerous
off-duty
law enforcement officers from around the
country
rooting out white supremacists and
right-wing extremists
is a challenge that local law
enforcement agencies and even
the united states military is facing
across
the country director ray how is the fbi
assisting law enforcement
agencies across the country to root out
white supremacy or other forms of
extremism
and you believe there's a concerted
effort by right-wing extremists to
infiltrate
law enforcement agencies
so i guess a few things i would say on
this topic
um certainly it is true that in some
instances
uh as we're uh continuing to investigate
the january sixth attack there have been
some instances of
current or particular former military
or law enforcement who participated and
we want to pursue those cases just as
aggressively as we would anybody else
we are also though which may go more to
the heart of your question
when appropriate uh referring
individuals to uh their
the department that employs them for
possible administrative or disciplinary
action
um under their rules as appropriate
we work very closely with both our law
enforcement partners and our military
partners
uh in their efforts to address any kind
of
violent extremism that may be in their
midst we view that as
in effect a kind of insider threat if
you will
and they do too and i want to be clear
that in my experience
and i'm dealing with our law enforcement
partners and our military partners every
single day
the vast vast vast vast vast vast
majority
of the men and women in uniform both in
law enforcement and the military
are brave selfless professional high
integrity individuals
but when there are bad apples in the
midst we work with our partners to uh to
try to get ahead of it
yeah i i i agree with that uh a final
statement but
the threat and the danger uh that those
few bad apples present
uh are uh to be taken very seriously and
understand so
hope to work with you possibly to
develop further best practices and
protocols
uh to be shared with uh agencies around
the country thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
tillis thank you mr chairman director
ray thank you for being
here for your years of service and for
the great work that
so many of the people in the fbi do
every single day
um before i ask you a question though i
think it's very important i was the last
member to leave the senate chamber
and i observed the capitol police doing
an extraordinary job
in shepherding every single member
and every single staff to safety
so i hope as they're reviewing some of
the the officers we should go through a
review i hope that we're tracking their
entire
pattern of movement that day i think
you'll see many of them were
doing uh putting themselves between us
and violence and we need to make sure
that we treat them fairly
but back on the rioters on january the
6th can you give me a rough idea just
of the crimes that many of them are
being charged with or being pursued
through investigations uh well we're
using a variety of
of statutory weapons there are certainly
assault charges
uh there are a number of charges that
are specific by that i mean assault
against
uh you know federal law enforcement uh
including the capitol police
uh uh the brave men and women of the
capitol police that i think you rightly
uh credited there there's also various
charges related to destruction of
federal property
things along those lines we are now
starting to
begin to see uh as we sort of taken care
of the most immediate easiest to prove
uh i hate to use a word like low-hanging
fruit charges but now we're starting to
get more of the more
uh advanced charges if you will so you
know we've had some conspiracy charges
recently
some of the people that are more
involved with different forms of
planning or coordination or
preparation and some of those charges
are starting to happen and i would
expect to see that continue
and uh incidentally mr chair i want to
associate myself with uh senator
graham's comments earlier i think your
threats are going up and uh we've got to
match that with additional resources so
i look forward to the
committee continuing that would you see
any
difference between the charges the
investigations that you're pursuing
in the events on january 6 and charges
that should be pursued against
federal buildings and federal law
enforcement officers being
harmed in seattle or portland are there
active investigations for either of
those two events and
would they be treated a different uh i
think said in response to an earlier
question uh we are equal opportunity
uh so by that i mean uh
we don't care what ideology motivates
you
if you're engaged in violence that
violates federal law we're coming for
you
uh and that's just true for the events
over the summer
uh and some of the domestic terrorism
that occurred are there active
investigations
related to those events yes thank you
you know i feel like
you mentioned in response to one of the
members questions about this
just increasing the volumes increasing
um
i've introduced in the last congress i
intend to reintroduce a bill called
protect and serve which increases
penalties for rioters for assaults on
federal officers
and more significant consequences do you
think
that those would be helpful tools for
law enforcement
uh certainly for prosecution sorry
didn't mean
uh i think uh while i'm not familiar
with the specific
bill uh i want to enthusiastically
support the idea of looking at
everything we can do
to protect the men and women of law
enforcement the threats
the violence against law enforcement in
this country
is one of the most tragic
and sometimes least talked about
challenges we face
this year alone this year alone
an officer is shot and killed in the
line of duty
at a rate of more than one a week
and when you think about what it takes
for someone
to be willing to sacrifice his or her
life for a total stranger
and how unusual that is just to begin
with
and then you add on top of that somebody
who's willing to do that
get up and do that every single day day
after day after day and they never know
when that day might be the day that they
don't come home to their families
and so then you put that in the context
of the way in which
some violent opportunists or domestic
terrorists hijack some of these protests
whether it's the ones over the summer or
the ones on the sixth
and now you've got some of these same
selfless individuals
um who are in many cases killed but
for everyone who's killed there's
someone who survived
thank goodness but whose life and his
family's life is forever altered
uh and i don't think we could ever and
should ever take for granted
those people because they protect all of
us i agree i'm
curious with all the discussion of
defund the police and systemic racism
and all
uh law enforcement agencies some of the
dialogue that's out there have you seen
any
measurable decrease in the number of
people who are trying to apply
to to come in to the fbi i know i'm
seeing it and
state troopers are telling me their
applications for academies are down by
over 70 percent um we see people
accelerating their retirements do we
have any potential threat out there
either within the fbi or for law
enforcement in general of having fewer
people willing to get into this
profession
so certainly when it comes to state and
local law enforcement because i talked
to
many of the same chiefs and sheriffs you
do uh the recruiting challenge
is a real concern and it comes up all
the time
that's something we need to be concerned
about and all of these trends that we're
talking about will have
i think we've run the risk of that just
making that trend worse
uh at the fbi happily
uh because we can all use some good news
from time to time
last year and the year before
we tripled the number of people
americans across the country applying to
be special agents so
when i took the job it was around 11 000
or so
a year people applying to be special
agents in 2019
it was about 36 000 and then last year
even with the pandemic it was even
higher than that and that's the highest
number of people applying to work at the
fbi as special agents to put their lives
on the line uh in about a decade
so uh we'd like to think our work
is earning people who want to come work
for us and we're grateful for that and
hopefully we can do our part to try to
encourage more people because we can
only take so many of them
to pursue law enforcement jobs in other
agencies well that is good news
i just wish you all the best of luck in
prosecuting
every single person that you can that
reach
the cab and every single person on the
grounds who assault it or
a police officer if there's anything
that we can do to help and i will
follow up with the department to get
your perspective as to whether or not
you think the protect and serve act
would be helpful
i think that it will be but i'd like
your professional judgment
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
senator ossoff
thank you mr chairman and uh director
ray uh greetings from your home state of
georgia thank you
thank you for your service there's been
a significant increase
in shootings and violent crime
nationwide over the last 18 months
there were at least 10 people shot in
atlanta georgia
on sunday what does the fbi assess is
driving
this crime wave well
uh certainly i am following the same
trend as you are with concern
not just uh not just in atlanta uh
but in other cities around the country
i'm not sure there's any single factor
that's driving it i think it's a variety
of things
um we are seeing um
[Music]
you know some of it may be um
you know the pandemic itself in its own
way has had an impact
um you know there are people who are are
maybe not at jobs or not
uh you know not in school or not
otherwise available and they're more
there's more potential for um for
wrongdoing to occur uh we've talked
about some of the challenges with local
police departments
uh and some of the issues there uh in
terms of their recruiting and staffing a
lot of them are understaffed
in addition to the recruiting challenge
so that's a problem
so the variety of drivers that we think
contribute to it but the violent crime
problem
over the last year in particular 2020
is something that is a great concern
that we are very rarely
keeping our eye on it doesn't get same
kind of headlines as some of the other
threats we've talked about today but
as your question i think quite rightly
implies it's a subject that's near and
dear to the hearts of all the people we
know back home
yeah well with that many shootings in
atlanta on sunday alone
this increase in violent crime is of
grave concern to
georgians people across the country will
you work with this committee
and my office to try to refine that
assessment of the drivers of this
violent crime wave
we'd be pleased to do that i i commend
you for your interest in the violent
crime problem back in our
state appreciate that uh director ray
next week will be the first anniversary
of the shooting death of brianna taylor
a young woman who died
when police officers in louisville
kentucky
entered her home with a battering ram
executing a no knock search wire
connected to a narcotics investigation
ms taylor was not the subject of that
warrant there's obviously been a
deepening and grave concern about
equal justice due process uh the extent
of uh
brutality harassment discrimination
faced by black americans in the criminal
justice system
growing over the last year given
incidents such as this one without
commenting on the specifics
of the les mis taylor's case is the fbi
prioritizing investigations of cases
involving color of law violations under
18 usc
242 and what resources have you
instructed
your field offices to commit to those
investigations
so as you say i can't discuss the taylor
case specifically uh we have an ongoing
federal investigation there but
uh we are definitely
uh we have we do that through our civil
rights division
uh within our criminal investigative
division
we are in addition to the investigations
number around the country we are also
trying to contribute
by doing different forms of training and
outreach to
state and local police departments so
they understand better
kind of where the where the lines are
and where we fit into it
so that's that's a you know part of it
as well uh
we're also trying to contribute to uh to
the situation
by encouraging better reporting
and we've had a lot of conversations
this morning in other contexts about
statistics
and reporting uh and when it comes to
use of force
we are trying to build out a use of
force database
that involves use of force by police
departments law enforcement agencies
around the country
it's voluntary we can't mandate all
these local police departments apply the
information
but we are doing a lot to encourage them
to submit their data and my pitch to
them has been
we're going to be talking about these
issues no matter what
and we should all want the conversations
to be based on the actual facts and the
actual data as opposed to what
some random person thinks the facts or
data are and so
we've we're out now reached one of the
thresholds where we can start doing some
of the reporting related to this effort
we need to get to a certain threshold
statistically
i think it's like 80 percent or
something of police department before
the data
is is considered statistically reliable
but so
investigations training and outreach uh
more complete statistical reporting on
use of force thank thank you director
ray and i know the committee is
considering legislation to make that
data more available to you from local
agencies and will you provide to the
committee into my office
an accounting of bis investigations
over the last two years color of law
violations title 18 usc 242.
happy to see if we can provide you some
more information on that okay
look forward to that thanks director ray
is the recently revealed solar winds
breach
a major cyber security breach
a failure a counter intelligence failure
by the u.s government
uh i don't know that i would describe it
that way
certainly the solar winds intrusion
is something that uh reflects a trend
that we've been
calling out for some time uh but it
takes it to the next level
so for years we've been warning of both
china and russia
in uh in efforts to inject
malware and and to undermine our trust
and software that
organizations all rely on we've also
called out
uh the intrusions into managed service
providers which allow our adversaries to
reach a far greater number of networks
through sort of single entry points
the solar winds intrusion essentially
takes this to the next level
purposely infecting a product that's
widely used to manage networks and so
the scope the scale the somewhat
indiscriminate nature
of the intrusion is something we take
very seriously with our partners
uh director ray my time being limited if
i might
surely for malware
to be embedded on sensitive us networks
at that scale and without detection for
that duration must constitute a
counterintelligence failure
well i think it's a cyber security issue
uh
i think of counterintelligence a little
bit differently um
than just the kind of context you're
talking about but as i said in some ways
it's analogous to what i said
about some of the earlier threats you
know we our goal is to try to bat a
thousand and anytime
we don't bat a thousand we're obviously
looking hard to see at what we can do
better
to prevent that from happening again
when it comes to
cyber intrusions in particular though
we are long past the world where
it's a question of if an organization is
going to be
the victim of cyber intrusion or in the
world of when
and the question is not whether somebody
was
subject to a cyber intrusion but how
fast does it get detected how well does
it get mitigated et cetera
the scope the scale the range of attack
methods the number of adversaries
involved in sophisticated cyber attacks
dwarfs what it was when i was in law
enforcement and national security before
and a huge amount of the information a
huge amount of the information
for america in particular is in the
hands of the private sector
and so unlike in some of the other kinds
of threats we've been talking about here
this morning
the partnership between the intelligence
community other federal agencies and the
protectors
is at the heart of the agent thank you
director
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
rossoff i'm glad you brought up solar
winds because i think it's first
reference at this hearing i'd like to do
a follow-up
before i recognize senator blackburn so
what do we do about it
we know that we don't have an
extradition agreement with russia
so even finding and naming the hackers
doesn't lead to any punishment of them
what is our response
as a deterrent to future cyber intrusion
so mr chairman i think
discussing the response in any detail is
probably something that would be better
done
um in a classified setting um that by
itself might
give you a little bit of a hint um but
what we have found speaking more
generally what we have found over the
last couple years
in the cyber arena in particular is that
we are at our most effective
when we have joint sequenced operations
uh that essentially think of it as the
having the whole be greater than the sum
of the parts so
you mentioned a few of the things that
can be done any one of those things by
themselves
ain't going to get the job done but if
you start putting some of those things
together
in a way where each amplifies the effect
of the other
we have actually seen some pretty good
results with some of our adversaries
so it's everything from not just the law
enforcement piece
it's foreign partner participation it's
private sector hardening
uh it's treasury sanctions it's a whole
host of things but when you put them
together
uh sequenced well i i would never
suggest to you and you would never
believe me if i did suggest to you that
that's gonna somehow just eliminate the
problem
it does push the adversary back and slow
their
progress but this is going to be a long
hard slog
thanks director i believe that senator
blackburn is on remote
senator
technical difficulties i want to
she's waited patiently so i'll give her
another minute
see if that helps yes mr chairman i'm
here
okay senator you have the floor
oh thank you sir i appreciate that and
yes i think i don't have enough ben
something's wrong with the video
transmission
we'll just go with audio and to the
chairman's
follow-up director ray i would just uh
like to add
i think it would be excellent and mr
chairman i would offer to you is we're
looking at what is happening
with cryptocurrencies and with the
growth in that marketplace
um and how this currency
could be used when it comes to
cyber crimes and to terrorism
i think a a briefing
from you all on what you are tracking
and what you're seeing
would be very helpful to us so
i would uh just um i
i would commend that as a second place
for us to go
and director ray i want to say thank you
to you
uh for being here and thank
you to the fbi and the u.s attorney's
offices in tennessee for the work they
did
after january 6 tracking down and
catching the rioters from tennessee
that had taken uh part in those
activities and there are a
a lot of questions that still remain one
and i know senator kennedy mentioned
this but the national guard
uh and the timeline that was there i'd
like for you to speak
to that if you can the day of timeline
because i understand that mayor bowser
spoke with the secretary of the army
twice
at 134 and 222 and
with chief son he spoke with the guard
the d.c
guard commanding general at 149
and the guard began to mobilize it three
and the troops did not arrive until 5
40.
is that your understanding of the
timeline but
senator i appreciate the question uh and
i'm glad you tied me back to
my exchange with senator kennedy because
i i fear that i may have contributed to
to a little bit of a muddle here so
first let me say that
my understanding is that on the question
of authority
is that the d.c mayor and the u.s
capitol police can ask for the national
guard
that the secretary of defense has the
authority
on federal land the secretary of the
army has authority on
in effect d.c or in when it's not d.c
state land i i really don't
have the specifics on exactly who
requested
what and when um and i understand why
why it's topic of keen interest but but
i as fbi director i'm not
intimately involved in that process and
so i don't want to add to
any confusion that's out there okay
so uh then it would be appropriate
that we direct that first of all
to the guard command and to
the secretary of the army is that what
i'm hearing you say
uh i think so yes okay
all right that sounds great thank you
for that clarification because i
do think that um
that we do need some clarification there
let me
uh go to some of the riots that have
taken place around the country
and the crime that has seemed to spike
this year and um previous to this the
fbi
participated in operation legend of
course memphis
tennessee was a part of
that effort so we thank you for that but
let me ask you
is the fbi tracking
extremist groups like antifa or
other radicalism that are connected to
violence
in cities across the country the
violence and the looting
that has taken place and we know
operation legend wound down and
ended in january so how
is the fbi going to continue assisting
local law enforcement
in these cities where you have
these riots that have taken place
well senator i appreciate the question i
think you've touched on two
uh very very important but distinct
topics um so one is the
the violence uh on our streets in a lot
of our major cities including memphis
that
that operation legend was designed to
address and the other is the violence
that's occurring amidst protests
where otherwise peaceful protests are
hijacked by people who engage in
in violent criminal behavior um
so on the first uh on what i would call
sort of the more traditional violent
crime
side the the in effect operation legend
side if i can just use that as a
shorthand
uh we do think that was a successful
operation
but it was by its very nature finite in
duration
what we're doing since then uh is trying
to
work with our safe streets task forces
which have uh representatives of
of state local and other federal
agencies
and to try to bring a strategic
intelligence-driven approach to the
violent crime problem what i have found
and i've talked with state and local
police chiefs in all 50 states
um is that each city has its own
idiosyncrasies there may be certain
common trends but
ultimately there's usually some kind of
in effect tail wagon the dog that
is contributing disproportionately to
the violent crime problem in that
community and if
everybody can be working together in an
intelligence-driven way
they can prioritize the impact uh and
dismantle the enterprise as opposed to
just
kind of pushing the problem around okay
let me
not to cut you off but to jump in there
because
you're correct there are different
sets of issues around
the different um the different types of
crime i understand that
and i appreciate that but i think part
of the frustration
is uh let's take july 4th last year with
the hatfield federal courthouse in
portland
with the fire that was started and how
did the fbi
and federal and local law enforcement
agencies
attempt to track down those that were
responsible
were it was this an extremist group
or groups or was it individuals
like a lone actor which you mentioned
earlier or and of course in nashville on
christmas day we saw the actions of a
lone actor
and separately at some point i would
like to
get a an update from you on that but
let's
talk about what you're doing to track
those groups that are there
or like in seattle with the capitol hill
autonomous zone where they're just
really uh flatting the rule of law
and uh trying to abolish a police
presence so how are you tracking these
anarchist groups
who are planning attacks who are
occupied
occupying public spaces and
what type work are you doing to help
protect communities from this
so sure uh so that's the second topic of
the two that we
touched on so uh we do have a number of
uh domestic terrorism investigations we
would call them
anarchist violent extremism
investigations
into individuals some of the most
dangerous individuals involved in some
of the conduct
in particular over the summer we
are looking at everything from tactics
to funding to logistics
uh and we're pursuing all available
charges against them
uh i think i may have mentioned in
response to an earlier question
uh that last year in 2020
we arrested more anarchist violent
extremists
than the prior three years combined um
and but in addition i would say that in
some of the activity that you've
described from over the summer
when it's targeting federal buildings
there are certain charges that may be
available
there as was true with the courthouse
in portland and as is true obviously
with the capital on the sixth
but when it comes to non-federal
facilities
sometimes the charges uh end up being
state local charges where we work
closely with and support our state and
local partners
uh as they bring charges so we are
continuing to move full speed ahead uh
we've increased significantly the number
of investigations into the kind of
activity you're describing
uh and we're going to keep at it
thank you so much uh thank you mr
chairman
thank you senator blackburn uh as we
conclude the hearing
in uh the area of shameless
self-promotion
i'm not gonna send you a qfr but i'd
like to send you a copy
of my domestic terrorism prevention act
to ask
for your reaction to it you may
suggest some changes to make it more
effective and i'd appreciate that
it's been a while since you've been
before the committee and we've certainly
tried your patience today but you've
been excellent in your presentation
and i just want to thank you and the men
and women of the federal bureau of
investigation for the
uh sacrifices they make to keep america
safe this
meeting of the judiciary committee will
stand adjourned thank you mr chairman
you